Hello, everyone. Hi, you guys. We are still on vacation. It's just a wonderful time to be home and with our families. But you know, we always like to pop in and say hi. It is almost a new year. 2022. OMG.
大家好。你们好。我们还在度假。现在是在家陪伴家人的美好时光。不过你们知道，我们总是喜欢突然出现和大家打个招呼。新的一年就要到了。2022年。天哪。
I know. Where does the time go? I don't know. I don't know. Well, listen, Ange, I thought it would be fun since we're approaching a new year to do a little deep dive on the history of New Year's. Oh, no way.
我知道。时间都去哪儿了？我不知道。我不知道。好吧，听着，安吉，既然快到新年了，我想我们可以深入探讨一下新年的历史，这样应该会很有趣。哦，不会吧。
Yes. I can't wait. I'm getting a cup of tea. I'm settling in. OK. So here's what I found out from my three to four articles that I Googled. In America, we celebrate the New Year with a celebration
真的。我等不及了。我去拿杯茶。我要安顿下来。好的。以下是我通过谷歌搜索三到四篇文章了解到的内容。在美国，我们庆祝新年有一种庆祝活动，
that sort of encompasses December 31st into January 1st. Yes. That's our big New Year's celebration. Yes. And you can take down your tree after that. Oh, we can't? That's what I'm telling you. I leave mine up till after New Year's.
这种活动有点把12月31日和1月1日结合在一起。是的。那是我们盛大的新年庆祝活动。是的。在那之后你就可以把圣诞树收起来了。哦，我们不能吗？我就是这个意思。我的圣诞树一直留到新年之后。
Well, we usually do too, but I'm just telling you out there. It's OK if it's up after New Year's. Have you ever had your tree up until, like, February? No. Like, what's the latest? Have you met my husband? It's coming down on January 2nd. He would pack it up on the 26th if I didn't stop him.
好吧，我们通常也这样，但我只是提醒你一下。新年过后还摆着也没关系。你有没有把圣诞树一直摆到二月份的时候？没有。那么，最晚是什么时候？你见过我丈夫吗？1月2日它就要被拿下来了。如果我不阻止他，他26号就会把它打包好。
That is true. All right. Well, listen, the earliest recorded New Year's festivities date back 4,000 years to ancient Babylon. However, they did not celebrate on December 31st, January 1st, because the calendar wasn't sort of the same calendar. They celebrated on the vernal equinox. And that is the day in late March
确实如此。好吧，听着，最早有记录的新年庆祝活动可以追溯到4000年前的古代巴比伦。然而，他们并不是在12月31日、1月1日庆祝，因为当时的日历和现在的日历不太一样。他们在春分时节庆祝。那是三月下旬的一天，
when there is an equal amount of sunlight and darkness. That was their New Year? That was their New Year on that day. Babylon, crazy. So in general, civilizations around the world developed calendars that would pin the New Year either on, like, an agricultural event or on an astronomical event.
那天阳光和黑暗的时间相等。那是他们的过年时间吗？那天就是他们的过年时间。巴比伦，太疯狂了。所以总的来说，世界各地的文明发展出的日历，都会把新年定在某个农业事件或天文事件上。
OK. So in Egypt, for example, the year began with the annual flooding of the Nile and the rising star Sirius. OK. The first day of the Chinese New Year occurred with the second moon after the winter solstice. OK.
好的。例如，在埃及，新年的开始伴随着尼罗河的年度泛滥和天狼星的升起。好的。中国农历的正月初一发生在冬至之后的第二个月。好的。
The early Roman calendar consisted of 10 months and 304 days. And the New Year also began at the vernal equinox. But guess what happened? What? Their calendar got out of sync with the sun. Huh? Yeah.
早期的罗马历法由10个月和304天组成。新年也是在春分时节开始。但你猜怎么着？什么？他们的日历和太阳不同步了。啊？对。
So in order to realign the Roman calendar with the sun, Julius Caesar consulted with all these astronomers and mathematicians. And in the year 46 BC, he added 90 days to the year. Can you imagine? Can you imagine? It's like, it's 46 BC. You feel like, what if you've had a tough year? Yeah.
因此，为了让罗马历法重新与太阳同步，尤利乌斯·恺撒咨询了所有的天文学家和数学家。在公元前46年，他在一年中增加了90天。你能想象吗？你能想象吗？这就好比，那是公元前46年。你会觉得，要是你度过了艰难的一年呢？对。
And you're like, it's almost over. I mean, it's almost a new year. And then Julius Caesar is like, guys, we're going to add 90 days to the calendar. You know what I can't stop thinking about is how did they get the word out? Because like, let's just talk about, you know, for example, our kid's school when there's something,
然后你觉得，快结束了。我是说，新的一年快到了。然后尤利乌斯·恺撒说，伙计们，我们要给日历增加90天。你知道我一直停不下来在想什么吗？就是他们是怎么把消息传达出去的？因为比如说，我们谈谈，比如，我们孩子的学校有什么事情发生时，
like a soccer game changes and the emails you get and the text you get. But what if you're not on the text thread and then you show up at soccer practice and it's not that day? How did they get the word out? I don't know. I feel like people were showing up for work.
比如足球比赛改期了，你收到的邮件和短信。但如果你不在短信群里，然后你出现在足球训练场上，结果那天没有训练？他们是怎么把消息传出去的？我不知道。我觉得当时有人去上班，
They're like, no, no, no, dude, dude, dude. We got like 90 more days of vacay or something. They're like, no, no, no, no, no. Actually, that was last year. That was last year. This is the new year. What are you talking about? Yeah.
他们会想，不，不，不，老兄，老兄，老兄。我们好像还有90多天的假期什么的。他们会说，不，不，不，不，不。实际上，那是去年。那是去年。今年是新年。你在说什么呢？对。
I mean, the Roman Empire was vast. How did they? It was a lot of scrolls. A lot of scrolls in different languages. Did they do like, hear ye, hear ye, news on the street? Yeah. 90 more days of the year. Yeah.
我是说，罗马帝国幅员辽阔。他们是怎么做到的？那得有很多卷轴。用不同语言写成的很多卷轴。他们是不是像这样，听着，听着，街头新闻？对。今年再多90天。对。
I don't know. I just felt like they're someone that showed up to work and, you know, they were like thinking it was one year, but it was the other year. I mean, can you imagine the paperwork problems? I don't know. Well, listen, he called this new calendar the Julian calendar. Of course he would.
我不知道。我只是觉得当时有人去上班，你知道，他们以为是那一年，结果却是另外一年。我是说，你能想象那 paperwork（文书工作）的问题吗？我不知道。好吧，听着，他把这个新历法叫做儒略历。他当然会这么叫。
Of course. And he also declared that January 1 would be the first day of the year. He named January in honor of the God Janus. And he wanted to give Janus the honor of starting the whole calendar. So Julius Caesar is the reason why our new year's in January? Yeah. Oh my gosh. However, we don't use the Julian calendar anymore.
当然。他还宣布1月1日是一年的第一天。他以雅努斯神的名义将一月命名为January。他想把开启整个日历的荣誉赋予雅努斯。所以尤利乌斯·恺撒就是我们把新年定在1月的原因？对。天哪。然而，我们不再使用儒略历了。
We actually use the Gregorian calendar, but it's very similar. And they also consider January 1st the first day of the year. So that's kind of how we got to January 1st. In the United States, we have the Times Square Ball Drop. That's our big tradition. Yes. I worked it with Carson Daly one year. I can't believe you did that.
我们实际上使用的是格里高利历，但它非常相似。他们也将1月1日视为一年的第一天。所以我们就是这样迎来1月1日的。在美国，我们有时代广场降球仪式。那是我们的重大传统。是的。有一年我和卡森·戴利一起做过这个节目。我真不敢相信你做过那件事。
I froze my- It's so cold. Yes. I was so cold. It was really fun. I can't believe I did it because I hate being cold, but I did it. That is epic. That is an epic like thing as a performer, as a comedian,
我冻得——太冷了。是的。我冷极了。这其实挺有趣的。我真不敢相信我做了这件事，因为我讨厌寒冷，但我还是做了。太酷了。作为一个表演者、喜剧演员、
actor to be part of that celebration. Live TV is terrifying. Well, this tradition has been going on since 1907. The ball started as a 700-pound orb made out of iron, wood, and 100 light bulbs. Only 100. Now it's like the Griswold's little like house in that Christmas vacation movie. It is now 12 feet in diameter.
演员，能够参与那样的庆祝活动，真是一件了不起的事。直播电视太吓人了。好吧，这个传统从1907年就开始了。那个球最初是一个700磅重的球体，由铁、木头和100个灯泡制成。只有100个。现在的它就像《疯狂圣诞假期》电影里格里斯沃尔德家的小房子一样。它现在的直径有12英尺。
It is 12,000 pounds. It is covered in LED lights and Waterford crystal. Very fancy. So that's it. Those are your like little New Year's tidbits. You can bring those out at your party this year and sound very knowledgeable about the New Year. Well, I loved that, Jenna.
它重达12000磅。它覆盖着LED灯和沃特福德水晶。非常花哨。就是这样。这就是你们的小新年趣闻。今年你们可以在派对上讲这些，听起来对新年非常了解。好吧，我很喜欢这个，珍娜。
I loved every single second. We will be back next week with an all-new episode. It's extra long. Yes. We will be breaking down the 100th episode of The Office, Company Picnic. Am I good or bad at volleyball? We'll tell you.
我喜欢每一个瞬间。我们下周将带着全新的一集回归。这一集特别长。是的。我们将剖析《办公室》的第100集《公司野餐》。我打排球是好还是坏？我们会告诉你的。
Before we go, one final reminder to please vote for us for the iHeart Podcast of the Year Award. We'd really love to win. Yes. You vote on Twitter by tweeting three hashtags. Hashtag Office Ladies, hashtag Podcast of the Year, hashtag iHeart Podcast Awards. The voting closes on January 2nd.
在离开之前，最后提醒大家，请为我们投票竞选iHeart年度播客奖。我们真的很想赢。是的。你在推特上发三个话题标签就可以投票。话题标签 Office Ladies，话题标签 Podcast of the Year，话题标签 iHeart Podcast Awards。投票于1月2日截止。
Yes. Tell your friends, have a little tweeting party and vote for us. All right. Let's re-listen to Traveling Salesman, also known as the Larry and Marjorie episode. Yes. Laundry and betrayal. Come on.
是的。告诉你的朋友，举办一个小型的发推派对并为我们投票吧。好了。让我们重新收听《旅行推销员》，也就是劳瑞和马乔里那一集。是的。洗衣和背叛。来吧。
Happy New Year. Happy New Year. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office re-watch podcast just for you.
新年快乐。新年快乐。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。我们是好朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了《办公室》终极重温播客。
Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hi, everybody. So if you see a photo of us podcasting, I am now in my husband's closet. Those are not my baseball hats.
每周我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。大家好。所以，如果你们看到一张我们录播客的照片，我现在是在我丈夫的衣帽间里。那些不是我的棒球帽。
That is his baseball hat collection. I like to wear baseball hats. You do. You are sort of like a baseball hat family. I feel like all of your family loves baseball hats. Oh, Lady, one Christmas we were trying to find a family photo that we could put on our Christmas card. And I couldn't find one where one of us wasn't wearing a hat.
那是他的棒球帽收藏。我喜欢戴棒球帽。你确实喜欢。你们家可以说是那种棒球帽家族。我觉得你们全家都喜欢棒球帽。哦，女士，有一年圣诞节，我们试图寻找一张可以放在圣诞贺卡上的全家福。结果我找不到一张我们中没有人戴着帽子的照片。
And so we decided to make it a bit. And we did a collage of just a baseball hat Christmas card. My mother-in-law was mortified. Mortified. She was like, why are you all in hats? Yes, baseball hats for your formal Christmas card. But yeah, it was like an inside joke. We're a hat family.
于是我们决定把它做成一个梗。我们做了一张全由棒球帽组成的圣诞贺卡拼贴画。我婆婆吓坏了。吓坏了。她说，你们为什么都戴着帽子？是的，为你们正式的圣诞贺卡戴上棒球帽。不过是的，这就像是一个内部笑话。我们是一个帽子家族。
We would fit in very well in Josh's closet, I guess is what I'm saying. I think you would. By the way, side note, your Christmas cards are always awesome. My favorite, and I have it hanging up in the kitchen still, is the one where you guys are all holding Sunny, your cat. Oh, yes. That was another fun collage.
我想我们会非常适合乔什的衣帽间，这就是我想说的。我想你会的。顺便说一句，题外话，你们的圣诞贺卡总是棒极了。我最喜欢的一张，现在还挂在厨房里，是你们所有人抱着你们的猫桑尼的那张。哦，是的。那是另一张有趣的拼贴画。
We had a good time with that. Lee has Sunny on his head. I'm holding Sunny upside down. It was a good one. Thanks, Lady. You guys have a floppy cat. And floppy cats are so great in photos. My cats would have like shredded our heads,
我们那次玩得很开心。李把桑尼顶在头上。我倒过来抱着桑尼。那是一张很好的照片。谢谢你，女士。你们有一只软绵绵的猫。而软绵绵的猫在照片里太棒了。我的猫会把我们的脑袋抓得粉碎，
like if we tried that. Okay, okay. So here we go. What are we doing today, Jenna? Today we are talking about season three, episode 12, traveling salesmen. Oh, it's so good. It's so good.
比如如果我们尝试那样做的话。好吧，好吧。那么我们开始吧。安吉拉，我们今天要做什么？今天我们要聊的是第三季第12集《旅行推销员》。哦，太棒了。太棒了。
I rewatched this one and the return with my kids. We all snuggled up in bed and watched them. They were laughing hysterically. Well, Angela, it's a good thing you watch those together. I did too because they were actually created to be kind of one big episode, to be watched together. And that is why they were written by three writers, Mike Scher, Lee Eisenberg, and Jean Stupnitsky.
我和孩子们一起重温了这一集和《回归》。我们都依偎在床上看着它们。他们笑得前仰后合。好吧，安吉拉，你们一起看这一集真是太好了。我也看了，因为它们其实就是被当作一集大制作来构思的，需要连在一起看。这也是为什么它们由三位编剧迈克·舒尔、李·艾森伯格和吉恩·斯图普尼斯基共同编写的原因。
And both of those episodes were directed by Greg Daniels. All right, Jenna. Well, why don't you hit us with a summary? All right. So in traveling salesmen, because that's the episode we're covering today, Dwight covers for Angela after she misses an important deadline.
这两集都是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导的。好吧，珍娜。要不你给我们来个总结？好的。那么在《旅行推销员》中，因为这是我们今天讨论的一集，德怀特在安吉拉错过了一个重要截止日期后替她掩盖。
The sales team all pair up for sales calls, but at the same time, Angela uncharacteristically invites Pam to coffee and then discusses her love life in code, but she discusses her love life. And then upon the return of the sales team, Michael learns that Dwight went to corporate behind his back. He doesn't know why.
销售团队都两两配对去进行销售拜访，但与此同时，安吉拉一反常态地邀请潘去喝咖啡，然后用暗号讨论她的感情生活，不过她确实讨论了她的感情生活。接着，随着销售团队的归来，迈克尔得知德怀特瞒着他去了总公司。他不知道为什么。
Dwight quits Dunder Mifflin. Yes. And then Karen finds out that Jim once had a thing for Pam. That's a lot of stuff. That's a lot of stuff. Phyllis, man, spilled the beans. I know Phyllis. Phyllis.
德怀特从邓德米夫林辞职了。是的。然后凯伦发现吉姆曾经对潘动过心。事情真多。事情真多。菲利斯，天哪，泄露了秘密。我知道菲利斯。菲利斯。
Okay, we'll get to that. We'll get to that. I bet you have some really good fast facts. Well, you know I do because you know that we got something. We did. All right. Here's what we got. All right.
好吧，我们会讲到那里的。我们会讲到那里的。我敢打赌你有一些非常棒的幕后快讯。嗯，你知道我有的，因为你知道我们有存货。我们确实有。好吧。这是我们准备的内容。好吧。
Fast fact number one. Like I said, both this and the next episode, the return were written and treated like one big episode. They were both directed by Greg Daniels. What do we do, Ange? Tell everybody what we did. We reached out to Greg and he sent in audio clips and they are fantastic.
幕后快讯第一条。就像我说的，这一集和下一集《回归》都是作为一集大制作来编写和对待的。它们都是由格雷格·丹尼尔斯执导的。安吉拉，我们做了什么？告诉大家我们做了什么。我们联系了格雷格，他发来了音频剪辑，它们太棒了。
And now Jen and I want him to send in audio clips every single week. Yes. His audio clips are so good. You guys were giddy about them. So the first thing we asked him was, what was the inspiration for this episode? And here is what he had to say.
现在珍娜和我都希望他每周都发音频剪辑。是的。他的音频剪辑太棒了。你们为之兴奋不已。所以我们问他的第一个问题是，这一集的灵感是什么？以下是他的讲述。
Travis Salesman and the return is a little two episode arc that we did as part of the working out of the merger of the two branches stories. Andy was always conceived in Gay Witch Hunt to be the Stanford version of Dwight. So it was natural that they butt heads when the branches merged. And we liked the idea that Dwight, as the hometown favorite,
《旅行推销员》和《回归》是我们为处理两个分公司合并的故事而制作的一个小型两集故事弧。安迪在《同性恋女巫大搜捕》中被构思为斯坦福版本的德怀特。所以当分公司合并时，他们针锋相对是很自然的。我们喜欢这样一个想法，即德怀特作为家乡的最爱，
gets to have a really strong and romantic arc here. You see a very noble side of him protecting the woman that he loves. And I think one of the reasons we made it two episodes was it didn't feel real to me or earned to have him leave and come back in only one episode. So it just felt a lot better to spread it out over two. And another part about that storyline was that it was pairings. And a writing exercise that I often did with the writers was
在这里有一个非常强烈且浪漫的故事弧。你看到了他高尚的一面，他在保护他所爱的女人。我想我们把它拍成两集的原因之一是，只用一集就让他离开又回来，对我来说感觉不太真实，也不够顺理成章。所以把它分摊到两集里感觉要好得多。关于那个故事情节的另一个部分是，它是两两配对的。我经常和编剧们一起做的一个写作练习是，
I'd have them try and come up with pairings of characters that we hadn't had scenes together before. And so this entire episode was fun pairings like Ryan and Stanley or Phyllis and Karen. And of course Angela and Pam, who have a great emotional storyline where they really are kind of growing as friends. And it was really cool to see Jim and Dwight, too,
我会让他们试着想出一些我们之前没有在一起拍过戏的角色组合。所以整集都是有趣的组合，比如瑞恩和斯坦利，或者菲利斯和凯伦。当然还有安吉拉和潘，她们有一个很棒的情感故事线，在那里她们真的作为朋友在成长。看到吉姆和德怀特也很酷，
and see their backstory. And then the other thing about Traveling Salesman was we used, in the client, we used being good at sales to make Michael more likeable. And in Traveling Salesman, you see a whole bunch of different characters and how they are as salespeople. And you see how great Jim and Dwight work together
并且看到了他们的背景故事。关于《旅行推销员》的另一件事是，在《客户》那一集里，我们利用擅长销售来让迈克尔更讨人喜欢。而在《旅行推销员》中，你看到了一大堆不同的角色以及他们作为销售人员的表现。你看到了吉姆和德怀特合作得多么出色，
and Michael being like a straight man for Andy, who's just terrible. And so it kind of helps distinguish the more likeable original Dwight versus the more sinister, schemy, you know, new Dwight. Keep talking. Talk forever, Greg. Talk forever.
以及迈克尔如何成为糟糕的安迪的性格衬托（直男角色）。所以这有助于区分更讨人喜欢的最初的德怀特与更阴险、爱搞阴谋的新德怀特。继续说。永远说下去，格雷格。永远说下去。
It's so fascinating. I love that not only were there these new pairings of characters, but also of writers. It's just so interesting. Yes. Yes, Ange. And so much comes out in this episode when you put these different people together
太迷人了。我喜欢不仅有这些新的角色组合，还有编剧的组合。这太有趣了。是的。是的，安吉拉。当你把这些不同的人放在一起时，这一集里涌现出了太多的东西，
for the first time, really. Yeah. So you guys, I don't know if we need to start some sort of a petition, but we really want to create a new feature of the show called Inspiration with Greg. And he will send us an audio clip
真的可以说是第一次。是的。所以你们大家，我不知道我们是否需要发起某种请愿，但我们真的很想为这个节目创造一个名为“格雷格的灵感”的新板块。他将向我们发送一段音频剪辑，
of the inspiration behind every episode. And there's like piano music. Greg will tell us the inspiration and then Kent tells us the nuts and bolts of how he made that inspiration happen. Greg is listening right now and is like, ladies, what are you signing me up for? Exactly.
讲述每一集背后的灵感。背景还会有钢琴音乐。格雷格会告诉我们灵感来源，然后肯特会告诉我们他是如何将灵感变为现实的具体细节。格雷格现在正在听，心里肯定在想，女士们，你们这是把我往哪个火坑里推啊？正是如此。
What is Fast Fact number two? Well, Angela, speaking of Kentopedia, Fast Fact number two is called Locations, Locations, Locations. So for this episode, because we actually shot it in conjunction with the return, we did something called crossboarding. It's a little lingo that they use in the biz.
幕后快讯第二条是什么？好吧，安吉拉，说到肯特百科，幕后快讯第二条叫做“地点，地点，地点”。所以对于这一集，因为我们实际上是与《回归》同时拍摄的，我们做了一件叫做“交叉拍摄”的事情。这是他们在业内使用的一个小行话。
Lingo alert. Show biz lingo alert. So crossboarding is when you shoot two episodes at once. We normally shot one episode each week, but we shot these episodes over a 10 day period from October 16th, 2006 to October 27th, 2006. And the main reason for this was because of locations. We just had a lot of places to go in these two episodes
行话警报。秀场行话警报。所以交叉拍摄是指同时拍摄两集。我们通常每周拍摄一集，但我们在2006年10月16日至2006年10月27日的10天时间里拍摄了这些集。这主要是因为地点的原因。在这两集中我们有很多地方要去，
and having the flexibility to shoot it over a two week period was really helpful. Yes. And they would also do a thing, you guys. They call it shooting out a location. So for example, every scene that happened in that coffee shop, they would film in one day. And then they could close out that location.
能够灵活地在两周内完成拍摄真的很有帮助。是的。他们还会做一件事，伙计们。他们称之为“拍完一个地点”。例如，发生在那个咖啡馆里的每一个场景，他们会在一天内拍完。然后他们就可以关闭那个地点了。
They don't have to pay for that location for multiple days. So sometimes when you crossboard, it's a great way to save money because you can shoot out a location. Yes. Have we bored you to tears? With a little behind the scenes lingo. Lingo alert.
他们不必为那个地点支付多天的费用。所以有时候当你进行交叉拍摄时，这是省钱的好方法，因为你可以拍完一个地点。是的。我们用一些幕后行话把你无聊透顶了吗？行话警报。
Shoot out a location. So since you brought up the coffee shop, Angela, we had a fan question from Brianna Kernan, Harshita Verma, and Molly Ottawa. Did Pam and Angela go to the same coffee shop that Jim and Karen end up going to later and is the coffee shop location the same one used in later episodes?
拍完一个地点。既然你提到了咖啡馆，安吉拉，我们收到了来自布里安娜·克纳恩、哈西塔·维尔马和莫莉·渥太华的粉丝提问。潘和安吉拉去的咖啡馆是不是吉姆和凯伦后来去的同一家咖啡馆？这个咖啡馆的外景地和以后剧集里用的是同一个吗？
Yes. Yes and yes. Yes and yes. And here's a little tidbit, Jenna. I don't know if you remember. That coffee shop was next door to the place we filmed the tattoo parlor scene. What?
是的。是的，是的。是的，是的。这里有个小趣闻，珍娜。我不知道你记不记得。那家咖啡馆隔壁就是我们拍摄纹身店场景的地方。什么？
Yes. An upcoming episode with Andy. That tattoo parlor was next to the coffee shop. It must be some little strip mall that Ken just had good favor with. So he was like, okay, we'll take that. We'll take that. Well, here's what Kent told me.
是的。安迪参演的下一集。那家纹身店就在咖啡馆旁边。那一定是个小商业街，肯特在那里很有面子。所以他当时想，好吧，我们要这个。我们要这个。好吧，这是肯特告诉我的。
He said the coffee shop was a real location. We filmed at a place called Java Groove Coffee. It was on Victory Boulevard in Van Nuys. Yes. However, it has been closed and replaced by a printing company. So I'm sorry if you come to LA, you cannot get a cup of coffee anymore
他说咖啡馆是一个真实的外景地。我们在范奈司一条叫维多利亚大道的叫做“爪哇律动咖啡”的地方拍摄的。是的。然而，它已经倒闭了，取而代之的是一家印刷公司。所以很抱歉，如果你来洛杉矶，你再也喝不到一杯咖啡了，
at Java Groove Coffee. Well, we'll have to find out if they can get a tattoo next door still. Yes, perhaps. What a fun office set tour that would be. You could go see the outside of Dunder Mifflin, grab a cup of coffee and get a tattoo. I mean, if you're a diehard fan,
就在爪哇律动咖啡。好吧，我们得去打听一下他们是不是还能在隔壁纹身。是的，也许吧。那将是一次多么有趣的办公室片场之旅啊。你可以去看看邓德米夫林的外景，喝杯咖啡，然后去纹身。我是说，如果你是一个铁杆粉丝，
right? Yep. But now you can just get something printed and then get a tattoo. All right. Well, I am not done talking about FastFact number two, Angela. Oh, I'm sorry.
对吧？是的。但现在你只能先打印点东西，然后再去纹身。好吧。嗯，我还没说完幕后快讯第二条，安吉拉。哦，我很抱歉。
There's more locations. We have so many more locations. This is a question from Kylan Hadley and Jordan Simpson. Were all the sets that the salesman traveled to local office buildings or were they built in the warehouse set like the fancy Stanford branch was? All right, are you ready?
还有更多的外景。我们有更多更多的外景。这是一个来自凯伦·哈德利和乔丹·辛普森的问题。销售员们去的所有布景都是当地的办公大楼，还是像高档的斯坦福分公司那样在仓库布景里搭建的？好吧，你准备好了吗？
Mm-hmm. They were not a set. They were a location, but they were all the same location. Here's what they did. The building where Jim and Dwight are in the parking lot and Dwight's like pumping himself up. That was in Van Nuys.
嗯哼。它们不是布景。它们是一个外景，但它们都是同一个外景。他们是这样做的。吉姆和德怀特在停车场的那场戏，德怀特在给自己打气。那是在范奈司。
It was at the Panorama Medical Plaza. Plaza, St. Louis. Was it at the Plaza? It was at the Plaza. Oh my gosh, that's so St. Louis. Oh my gosh, I have a St. Louis catch later in the episode, but that's the first one. Plaza, Plaza.
它在全景医疗广场。广场，圣路易斯。它是在广场吗？它是在广场。哦天哪，太圣路易斯了。哦天哪，我在这集后面还有一个圣路易斯梗，但这是第一个。广场，广场。
So at the Panorama Medical Plaza, they found a completely vacant floor, and they dressed five different spaces to be the various offices that everyone visits. Isn't that amazing? They took one location and made it five different places, but there's more. Oh, more?
所以在全景医疗广场，他们找到了一个完全空置的楼层，他们把五个不同的空间装扮成每个人访问的不同办公室。这不是很神奇吗？他们用了一个外景地拍出了五个不同的地方，但还不止于此。哦，还有？
So you know how we said we shot these two episodes together? In the next episode, the return, at the beginning you see Dwight going around with his resume, two of those offices were also part of the Panorama Medical Building. That Plaza covered a lot of ground, lady. So much Plaza. So one thing, the church scenes with Stanley and Ryan, those were filmed at the Panorama Presbyterian Church on Roscoe.
所以你知道我们刚才说我们把这两集拍在一起了吗？在下一集《回归》中，一开始你看到德怀特拿着简历四处奔走，其中有两个办公室也是全景医疗大楼的一部分。那个广场占地很广，女士。有太多的广场了。所以有一件事，斯坦利和瑞恩的教堂场景，是在罗斯科的全景长老会教堂拍摄的。
So that was another separate location, and then there's even staples, but we'll talk about that next week. So many locations. So many. All right, I think we've covered all the locations. Let's move on to fast fact number three. Another fan question.
所以那是另一个独立的外景，然后还有史泰博，但我们下周会聊到那个。有那么多的外景。太多了。好吧，我想我们已经讲完所有的外景了。让我们进入幕后快讯第三条。另一个粉丝提问。
Okay. Guys, we love your questions. They are so helpful in structuring the podcast. Thank you. All right, fan question Rachel Labish and Rebecca Kelly said, I noticed a weird discrepancy between the Netflix episodes and the DVD episodes. In the DVD episodes,
好的。伙计们，我们喜欢你们的问题。它们对构建播客结构很有帮助。谢谢。好吧，粉丝提问瑞秋·拉比什和丽贝卡·凯利说，我注意到Netflix播出的剧集和DVD播出的剧集之间存在一个奇怪的差异。在DVD播出的剧集中，
there is a whole subplot about Pam winning an art contest. In the Netflix version of the episode, the whole thing is cut out. I haven't been able to find anything online about it. Do you know why this is? Ladies, that is a fantastic question because this whole podcast almost went haywire because Jenna was watching the Netflix episode
有一个关于潘赢得艺术比赛的完整副线剧情。而在Netflix版本的剧集中，整段都被删掉了。我在网上找不到任何关于这方面的资料。你知道这是为什么吗？女士们，这是一个非常棒的问题，因为这个播客差点就乱套了，因为珍娜看的是Netflix版，
and I was watching the DVD episode and they're totally different. Angela and I were so confused because we were trying to outline this episode and there were all these scenes that Angela was talking about that I remembered shooting Angela, but that weren't in the version I was watching. Yeah.
而我看的是DVD版，它们完全不同。安吉拉和我很困惑，因为我们试图列出这一集的提纲，安吉拉谈到的所有这些场景，我都记得我们拍摄过，安吉拉，但它们不在我看的版本里。是的。
So I started digging around and here is what I found out. On March 15, 2007, NBC aired a repeat of this episode, but they didn't want to air an exact repeat. They wanted to get more viewers, so they called it a new Pete. A new Pete. You know, when they would run repeats, they wouldn't get as many viewers,
于是我开始四处搜寻，以下是我发现的情况。2007年3月15日，NBC播出了这一集的重播，但他们不想播出一模一样的重播。他们想吸引更多观众，所以他们称之为“新重播”。新重播。你知道，当他们重播旧剧集时，吸引不到那么多观众，
which meant fewer ad dollars for commercials, right? Because that's how networks make money. So they thought if we add a new Pete, where it's mostly the old episode, but then some stuff you've never seen before, maybe it would up the viewership. And that's why there are now like these two different versions of this episode living out in the world
这意味着广告商的广告费会减少，对吧？因为那是电视网赚钱的方式。所以他们认为如果我们增加一个“新重播”，其中大部分是旧剧集，但也有一些你从未见过的内容，也许它会提高收视率。这就是为什么现在世界上存在着这一集的两个不同版本，
because somebody in marketing at NBC came up with this new Pete idea. I don't think we ever did that again. I think this is our one and only new Pete. Am I right? Well, I guess it happens again in season four when Phyllis tells Jim about her house that Bob bought her.
因为NBC市场部的人想出了这个“新重播”的主意。我想我们再也没有那样做过了。我想这是我们唯一的一次“新重播”。我说的对吗？嗯，我想在第四季当菲利斯告诉吉姆关于鲍勃给她买的房子时，这种情况又发生了。
It's on the DVD, but it's cut out of the Netflix version. So here's what's on the DVD. First of all, Traveling Salesman and the Return are one episode on the DVD. They're not two episodes. They're one like super sized, huge episode. Crazy, right?
DVD上有这一段，但被从Netflix版本中删掉了。所以DVD上的内容是这样的。首先，在DVD上，《旅行推销员》和《回归》是一集的。它们不是两集。它们是一集超长的大剧。很疯狂，对吧？
Crazy. But in the Traveling Salesman, these are the scenes you missed if you watched it on Netflix. Pam gets a phone call that a watercolor she made won a sixth grade elementary school art contest. I remember shooting it.
疯狂。但在《旅行推销员》中，如果你在Netflix上观看，以下是你错过的场景：潘接到一个电话，说她制作的一幅水彩画赢得了六年级小学美术比赛。我还记得拍摄那场戏。
These sixth graders picked your art. You were really excited. You won $100. You were really excited to tell Kevin about it. Kevin's like, yeah, well, I won $400 betting on a Celtics game. And you were like, okay, thanks for that, Kevin. And then she tells Angela.
这些六年级学生选中了你的艺术品。你当时真的很兴奋。你赢了100美元。你真的很想把这件事告诉凯文。凯文说，哦，好吧，我在凯尔特人比赛上押注赢了400美元。然后你说，好吧，谢谢你的分享，凯文。接着她把这事告诉了安吉拉。
Pam is just desperate to tell someone that her art won and no one's in the office. They're all out on a sales call. So she pops up over the partition. Jenna, we have one of those classic over the partition, Angela and Pam scenes. And she tells Angela, and Angela has all this good favor
潘迫切地想找个人分享她的艺术品获奖的喜悦，但办公室里一个人也没有。他们都出去进行销售拜访了。所以她从隔板探出头来。珍娜，我们有了经典的隔板探头安吉拉和潘的场景。她告诉了安吉拉，而此时安吉拉对潘满心好感，
in her heart towards Pam right now. You know, they've gone and got coffee. They've bonded. And so Angela goes, congratulations. And then she says, I really like having these little moments with you. And then she offers Pam, one of her kittens, Sprinkles has had kittens,
你知道的。她们一起去喝了咖啡。她们建立起了感情。所以安吉拉说，恭喜你。然后她说，我真的很喜欢和你一起度过这些小时光。接着她提议送给潘她的一只小猫，小饼干生了小猫，
and she offers Pam the dominant male named Ash. And Pam clearly does not want this cat. She makes up excuses. She's like, oh, you know, my landlord, it's just, it's a thing. And you know, it'd be, I don't know. And Angela is like, F you. She instantly goes back to being
她把那只名叫“灰烬”的霸道公猫送给潘。而潘显然不想要这只猫。她找借口推脱。她说，哦，你知道，我的房东，这只是一回事。而且你知道，这会，我不知道。然后安吉拉就像是，去你的。她瞬间又回到了，
just this cold snarky person to Pam. That's it. Their friendship's over. It was so fleeting. And then lastly, when Jim finally comes back from his sales call, Pam is so excited to tell him, and he's on his way out to have coffee with Karen.
那个对潘冷嘲热讽的刻薄人。就是这样。她们的友谊结束了。真是转瞬即逝。最后，当吉姆终于结束销售拜访回来时，潘兴奋极了，想把这个好消息告诉他，而他正准备出去和凯伦喝咖啡。
And Pam's like, Jim, and he starts talking to her about it. And Karen's like, we're going to get coffee. So it's this awkward moment. I remember shooting all of that. Here's the other thing I found really interesting. So in the opening scene of the Netflix version,
潘喊着，吉姆，而他开始跟她谈论这事。凯伦说，我们要去喝咖啡了。所以这是一个尴尬的时刻。我记得把所有这些都拍下来了。还有一件事我觉得很有趣。所以在Netflix版本的开场场景中，
it's Harvey, the computer, right? Yeah. Talking to Jim. That's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. That's not even in the episode. Oh, so I, because I was wondering, well, what did they cut out of the episode in order to make room for Pam's art contest?
那是哈维，那台电脑，对吧？是的。在跟吉姆说话。那是DVD上的删减片段。它甚至不在正片里。哦，所以，因为我在想，好吧，为了给潘的艺术比赛腾出空间，他们在正片里剪掉了什么？
So there must be things when they aired this on NBC, there must be things missing. In the deleted scenes on the DVD, there's a lot of extra scenes in the cars driving. Yeah. There's a lot of extra driving scenes. And then there's this Harvey the talking computer. That's a deleted scene.
所以当NBC播出时，肯定有些东西不见了。在DVD的删减片段中，有很多车内驾驶的额外场景。是的。有很多额外的驾驶场景。然后还有这个会说话的电脑哈维。那是删减片段。
Wow. So there you go. We are going to be following along the Netflix airing because that way our time codes will match up. But that's what you will get if you go to the DVDs. I love it. I love it. I feel like I'm really happy with all of that.
哇。所以就是这样。我们将跟着Netflix的播出版本走，因为这样我们的时间码就能对上了。但如果你去看DVD，你就会看到那些内容。我喜欢。我喜欢。我觉得我对这一切都很满意。
I think we should take a break and then come back and break down the episode. Sounds great. All right. We're back. Let's dive right in this episode. Michael is really excited to show Jim and Pam, his new computer.
我想我们应该休息一下，然后回来剖析这一集。听起来不错。好的。我们回来了。让我们直接深入探讨这一集。迈克尔非常兴奋地向吉姆和潘展示他的新电脑。
It's his buddy, his talking friend, Harvey. Oh my gosh. And basically he types into the keyboard and Harvey says stuff. Yes. And he's made the back of the computer like a face. Like he used some post-it notes. Anyway, Harvey is this talking computer.
那是他的好伙伴，他的会说话的朋友，哈维。哦天哪。基本上他在键盘上打字，哈维就会说话。是的。他还把电脑背面弄得像一张脸。就像他用了一些便签纸一样。总之，哈维就是这台会说话的电脑。
Well, we got a fan question from Bailey Aspinson, Becky Gemmel, Megan Keele, Chelsea Lane, and Alyssa Sorensen. Everyone wants to know who is the voice of Harvey. Oh, that's a great question. Who is it? I recognized it immediately. And did you recognize it, Angela?
好吧，我们收到了来自贝利·阿斯平森、贝基·杰梅尔、梅根·基尔、切尔西·莱恩和阿丽莎·索伦森的粉丝提问。每个人都想知道哈维的声音是谁配的。哦，这是一个好问题。是谁配音的？我立刻就听出来了。安吉拉，你听出来了吗？
Oh, no, I didn't. Oh, no. As soon as I heard the voice, I was like, oh, it's Mike Scherr. Oh my gosh. That's such a great cat. So I emailed him and he was like, yes, it's me. I was Harvey. So he's the one that said, me so horny,
哦，没有，我没有。哦，没有。我一听到那个声音，我就想，哦，是迈克·舒尔。天哪。这真是一个伟大的梗。所以我给她发了电子邮件，他说，是的，就是我。我就是哈维。所以就是他说出了那句，“me so horny，me love you long, Tim”。
me love you long, Tim. Yes, exactly. And Pam's like, oh, I'd love to meet long, Tim. And you and John played off, Steve, and that scene made me laugh so hard because Michael's just gets so frustrated that you guys aren't thinking his talking computer is amazing. Well, some people notice that when we cut away to Michael's
是的，完全如此。潘说，哦，我很想见见长姆（Long Tim）。你和约翰配合史蒂夫的表演，那个场景让我笑得前仰后合，因为迈克尔看到你们觉得他的会说话电脑一点也不神奇，气得不行。好吧，有些人注意到当我们切换到迈克尔的
screen, what he's been typing doesn't quite match with what you've been hearing. That's just because the scene was longer. And we actually did have Harvey say all those lines and we had lines. But then in the editing room, they cut some of them out. So the screen was indicative of the scene as written. And it got a little trimmed down in the editing room.
屏幕时，他打的字与你听到的并不完全一致。那只是因为这一场戏拍得更长。而且我们确实让哈维说完了所有那些台词，我们也有台词。但在剪辑室里，他们剪掉了一些。所以屏幕上显示的文字符合剧本中写的那场戏。而在剪辑室里它被稍微精简了一下。
So that's why his screen doesn't quite match. Some really good fan catches right away. I know. All right. So now Angela, we move over to accounting. And Kevin tells Angela that corporate did not receive their tax forms. But Angela says, no, no, they arrived this morning.
所以这就是为什么他的屏幕显示不太吻合的原因。有很多非常棒的粉丝捕捉力。我知道。好吧。那么现在安吉拉，我们转到会计部。凯文告诉安吉拉，总公司没有收到他们的税务表格。但安吉拉说，不，不，它们今天早上就到了。
And he wants you to know how very important this is. Angela, here's what I wrote down when I watched this scene. What? WTF is up with your hair. Why do you have a flower of hair on the back of your head? Guys, I took a picture and I'm going to post it because it's insanity. What is happening?
他想让你知道这有多么重要。安吉拉，当我看到这个场景时，我写下了这样的话。什么？你的头发到底怎么了。为什么你脑后有一朵头发花？伙计们，我拍了一张照片，我要把它发出来，因为这太疯狂了。这到底是怎么回事？
When we got the script, Kim Ferry and I started talking. Kim is who did our hair. And we were like, you know, Angela is happy in this episode. Now she starts out in the morning a little worried, right? Did Dwight make it? Is everything going to be okay? But she's a lady in love and her man has done this amazingly gallant thing for her.
当我们拿到剧本时，金·费里和我开始讨论。金是给我们做头发的人。我们当时想，你知道，安吉拉在这集里很高兴。现在她一早开始时有点担心，对吧？德怀特成功了吗？一切都会顺利吗？但她是一个坠入爱河的女人，她的男人为她做了这件极其英勇的事。
And I feel like she's sort of dressing the part of like this lady in love. She's wearing her Janet Jackson Rhythm Nation mini short sleeve jacket. That's made a callback. And she did a little something extra fancy with her hair. Kim and I just thought maybe she's just a she's taking it up a notch. Yeah, she turned her hair into a pinwheel flower.
我觉得她有点在打扮得像个坠入爱河的女人。她穿着她的珍妮·杰克逊《Rhythm Nation》短袖夹克。这是一个回顾。而且她在头发上做了一些额外花哨的事情。金和我只是觉得也许她只是，她把事情提升到了一个新的高度。是的，她把头发盘成了一朵风车花。
And clearly she has eight arms and multiple mirrors because how do you do that to the back of your head? Well, when I saw that hair, all I could think about was, oh my gosh, she couldn't lay down during her breaks. Because sometimes at lunch, I would want to, you know, lay back after I eat, maybe snooze it out because we would get up real early. Sometimes I need a little snooze at lunch.
显然她有八只手和好多面镜子，因为你怎么能对自己的脑后做这种事？好吧，当我看到那个发型时，我脑子里想的全部都是，哦天哪，她在休息的时候肯定没法躺下。因为有时在午饭后，我可能会想，你知道，吃完饭后躺一会儿，也许小睡一会儿，因为我们起得很早。有时候我午饭时需要小睡一会儿。
But you, you couldn't do that that week, I guess, can lay on that. That would be so uncomfortable. I couldn't even lean back on a chair, lady. I couldn't even recline in any way. Guys, check it out. You don't have to look hard. It's insane.
但你，那周你可做不到，我猜，没法躺在那个上面。那会非常不舒服。女士，我甚至没法靠在椅子上。我甚至没法以任何方式躺椅。伙计们，去看看吧。你们不用费力去找。太疯狂了。
It's also amazing. We had a lot of people write in Julia Lee, Bethany Devish, Kaley Wading, Anita Prasad. They all said Angela's hair looks incredible in this episode. Thank you. Thank you very much. And now we're going to come up onto this talking head that Rashida actually mentioned when she was a guest on
这也太神奇了。我们有很多人写信来，朱莉娅·李、贝瑟尼·德维什、凯利·瓦丁、安妮塔·普拉萨德。他们都说安吉拉在这集里的发型看起来不可思议。谢谢。非常感谢。现在我们要来到这个由Rashida（拉什达）提到的脱口秀场景，她在做客《班尼哈娜》时曾提到过，安迪谈到他和凯伦是最后留下的两个人，对吧？
Benihana, where Andy talks about him and Karen being the last two left standing, right? And Andy says he's not going to be one of the kids touring Willy Wonka's factory. He will not fall into the chocolate river. I loved that reference. I loved it too. But all I could think about, Jenna, is that he does fall into
安迪说他不会成为参观威利·旺卡工厂的孩子之一。他不会掉进巧克力河里。我喜欢那个梗。我也很喜欢。但我能想到的全部，珍娜，是他的确掉进了
the lake. When? At beach games. Totally forgot that. He falls into the lake. He's in a giant sumo suit and he floats on by and I couldn't help but think what an amazing like callback to the Willy Wonka River thing.
湖里。什么时候？在沙滩运动会上。完全忘了那件事。他掉进湖里了。他穿着一件巨大的相扑服漂了过去，我不禁想到这简直是对威利·旺卡巧克力河梗的一个绝妙回应。
I don't know. I thought that was kind of fun. Oh my God. Yeah. I totally. Yes. I'm so sorry. It's all coming back to me.
我不知道。我觉得这挺有趣的。哦天哪。是的。我完全。是的。我很抱歉。这一切都浮现在我脑海里了。
We'll get to it when we talk about beach games. But yes, Ed slowly floating away. I remember it now so clearly. So Angela, now you're standing at reception. You're getting yourself some jelly beans and Dwight comes in. It's so sweet. He lets you know the tax forms have been delivered. Yes.
我们聊到沙滩运动会时会讲到这个。但是的，埃德慢慢地漂走了。我现在记得很清楚了。所以安吉拉，现在你站在接待处。你在给自己拿糖豆，德怀特进来了。太甜了。他让你知道税务表格已经送到了。是的。
You guys are kind of talking in code, but of course Pam is clocking it all. And then as you walk away, you say, I don't want these and you leave the jelly beans. We had a fan question. Okay. Ally Joe Higginbotham says, did Angela improv that line? I don't want these to Pam after she took the jelly beans.
你们在用暗号交谈，但潘当然把这一切都看在眼里。然后当你走开时，你说，我不要这些了，并把糖豆留下了。我们有一个粉丝提问。好的。艾莉·乔·希金伯顿说，那是安吉拉即兴发挥的台词吗？在拿了糖豆后对潘说“我不要这些了”。
Yes. Yes, I did. The note that Greg had given me in that scene is that, you know, I'm so anxious to talk to Dwight to find out that everything went okay, but I had to make some business for myself. Like why would I be at reception? So I decided to kind of dig in the jelly beans. I just sort of was like, oh, this is what I'll do.
是的。是的，我是即兴的。格雷格在那场戏中给我的提示是，你知道的，我非常急于和德怀特谈谈，想知道一切是否顺利，但我必须给自己找点事做。比如我为什么会在接待处？所以我决定在糖豆堆里翻找一下。我只是觉得，哦，我会这么做。
So I was digging in the jelly beans and I put a few in my hand throughout the scene. And then as Dwight walked away, I just had them in my hand. So I just placed them on the countertop like your kid would. I don't like this. Yes. Just walked away and it just tickled us so much and they left it in.
所以在整场戏中，我一直在糖豆里翻找，手里抓了几颗。然后当德怀特走开时，我手里正拿着它们。所以我只是像你的孩子那样把它们放在了柜台上。我不喜欢这个。是的。就这样走开了，这让我们觉得太好笑了，他们把它保留了下来。
But the part I love even more Jenna is your look, your look of like, it said so much to me in the moment. It said people leave their water bottles and their trash on my desk all the time. After you would leave the jelly beans, I added a little bit that got cut out and probably it should have been cut out because it just would have gone on forever. But I would find all these various ways to get rid of the
但我更喜欢的部分是你的表情，珍娜，你的表情，在那个时刻说明了太多问题。它说明了人们总是把水瓶和垃圾留在我的桌子上。在你留下糖豆之后，我加了一小段被剪掉的内容，也许本该把它剪掉的，因为它会没完没了。但我会想出各种各样的方法来处理这些糖豆。
jelly beans. So I remember one time I picked up the trash can and I scooched them into the trash can using a piece of paper. And another time I like took a tissue and I picked them up with a tissue. And another time I think I picked them up and put them back in the jelly bean container. But I had all these ways that I got rid of these jelly beans
所以我记得有一次我拿起垃圾桶，用一张纸把它们扫进垃圾桶里。还有一次我拿了一张纸巾，用纸巾把它们捡起来。还有一次我想我把它们捡起来放回了糖豆罐里。但我有各种各样的方法来摆脱这些糖豆。
and I had a good time with that. None of them made it in of course, but it was just kind of like a fun little bit we were doing. So should we move into the conference room now, Angela? Oh yeah, because somebody needs to pass the tardy sauce. Yes. The entire sales team is assembled in the conference room and Dwight comes in late.
我当时觉得挺有意思的。当然，他们谁也没有被选中，但我们当时就是随便排练了一下，觉得蛮好玩的。安吉拉，那我们现在去会议室好吗？哦，对呀，因为得有人去拿那份迟到酱了。对。整个销售团队都聚集在会议室里，而德怀特迟到了。
So Andy is such a tool. Oh my gosh. So at the beginning of this scene, Michael explains that this is his dream team. This is my dream sales team. And we're going to pair up and go on some sales calls. And we had a fan question from Holly Anderson. Holly Anderson says, Phyllis blows her nose right after
安迪真是个十足的傻瓜。天呐。这场戏刚开始时，迈克尔解释说这是他的梦之队。这是我的梦之队。我们要组队出去跑几个销售业务。我们收到了来自霍莉·安德森（Holly Anderson）的粉丝提问。霍莉·安德森说，菲莉丝在刚……
Michael says, this is my dream team. Was that scripted? I wondered the same thing because it's brilliant. The timing is so perfect. It's so perfect. Yes, it was scripted. Amazing. Here is the script direction.
迈克尔说完“这是我的梦之队”之后，菲莉丝就擤了鼻涕。这是剧本里写好的吗？我也一直在纳思这个问题，因为这实在是太绝了。时机把握得太完美了。简直太完美了。是的，剧本里就是这么写的。太棒了。剧本上的台词提示是这样的。
Quote, the camera pans to board faces of the sales team. Phyllis blows her nose. And you know, I got a guy's, I, this is a little moment because I watched it several times. It's so great. Phyllis gets out her little tissue. She sniffles a little bit and then she blows her nose. Like she times it perfectly, but she starts the bit a little
原文是，“镜头切向销售团队板着面孔的特写。菲莉丝擤了鼻涕。”你们知道吗，我看了好几遍这个桥段，这真是一个绝妙的小细节，太棒了。菲莉丝掏出她的小纸巾，轻轻吸了一下鼻子，然后开始擤鼻涕。她把时间掐得刚刚好，不过她这个小动作开始得有点……
early. And I think that's what sells making it look so organic. It's, it's really wonderful work. Little details. Phyllis, man, with the tissue work. So everyone gets paired up. Yes. We get Karen and Phyllis and Ryan and Stanley, Dwight and Jim
早。我觉得正是这一点，才让整个画面显得那么自然。这真的是一段非常精彩的表演。小细节啊。菲莉丝，在处理纸巾这方面可太有一套了。于是大家都组好了队。是的。凯伦和菲莉丝一组，瑞恩和斯坦利一组，德怀特和吉姆……
and Michael and Andy. Now they're going to go out and be in cars together all day. I couldn't wait. I remember when we got the script in at the table read, when I saw like the groupings, I was like, oh, this is going to be so fun. Well, there's a Ryan talking head in here that makes me laugh so hard.
还有迈克尔和安迪。接下来他们一整天都要一起坐在车里出去了。我当时简直迫不及待。我还记得我们在围读剧本时，当我看到这些分组时，我就想，哦，这一定太有意思了。剧中有一个瑞恩的“面对镜头独白”，把我笑得不行。
Because you are now Ryan in real life. I am now Ryan. I love it that he said he's flattered to be Stanley's second choice after pass, after pass. Stanley got to pick his partner and his first response was pass. And his second response was, I guess he'll take the kid. Well, I wanted to talk really quickly about Jim's talking
因为你现在在现实生活中就是瑞恩了。我现在的确就是瑞恩。我太喜欢他说的那句话了，他说被斯坦利选为第二人选让他感到受宠若惊，在排除了、排除了……斯坦利选搭档时，他的第一反应是“放弃”。而他的第二反应是，他猜自己只能勉为其难带上这个小年轻了。好了，我真的很想快速聊聊吉姆的……
head. He holds up that photo of Dwight and Jim, like the old photo because they clearly, they clearly have been on a ton of sales calls together, right? And it shows their history a little bit, which I love. But in the DVD commentary, Rain said that his hair in that photo was from 1991. He was on tour with an acting company doing Romeo and Juliet.
独白。他举起了那张德怀特和吉姆的旧照片，就像是老照片一样，因为他们显然、显然一起跑过无数次销售业务了，对吧？这张照片稍微展现了一下他们的过去，我超喜欢。不过在DVD花絮评论中，雷恩说照片里他那头头发是1991年的。当时他正在跟一个剧团巡演，演《罗密欧与朱丽叶》。
And they all had long Elizabethan hair. And they sort of, they sort of like Photoshopped it on to current Dwight, but they left that big hair. I just thought it was hilarious. I love that detail. I know. So now they're all in the parking lot. They're paired up into their teams.
他们当时都留着那种伊丽莎白时代的披肩长发。他们就把那头发P到了现在的德怀特头上，但保留了那头蓬松的长发。我觉得这太搞笑了。我太喜欢这个细节了。就是说啊。现在他们都在停车场了。他们各自和搭档分好了组。
They're about to get in their cars and go. Michael tosses Dwight, his dirty laundry, which is a callback to the coup. I love it when our show does this and we have a few in this episode, but this is a callback to the coup. And now he tells them all to circle up and he's going to give them their marching orders. Yeah.
他们正准备上车出发。迈克尔把他的脏衣服扔给德怀特，这是在呼应政变那一集。我太喜欢我们剧里的这种呼应了，这集里还有好几处，但这绝对是对政变一集的致敬。接着他让大家围成一圈，准备给大家下达任务指令。对。
So then Michael says, guys, let's, let's go out on our sales calls. This is, it's like the, we're the amazing race and everyone's like, how are we the amazing race? Is there a prize? He's like, no, there's no prize. But we're the amazing race. And he keeps, gives everybody these team names and everyone's
然后迈克尔说，伙计们，我们出发去跑销售业务吧。这感觉就像是，我们是极速前进，然后每个人都一脸懵：我们怎么就成极速前进团队了？有奖品吗？他说，没有，没有奖品。但我们就是极速前进。接着他给每个人都起了这些战队名，大家……
very confused. And then Michael just gets frustrated. He's like, just go on your sales call. But I love that he brought up the amazing race. This was a really, really popular reality show at the time. And I was a huge fan. Jenna, we were so into it. I remember you and I watching the amazing race.
都非常疑惑。然后迈克尔就有点沮丧了。他说，你们直接去跑业务就行了。但我真的很喜欢他提起《极速前进》。这是当时非常、非常火爆的一档真人秀节目。而且我是它的超级粉丝。珍娜，我们当时可迷了。我还记得你和我一起看《极速前进》呢。
And then Jenna, do you remember how you and I were like, we should go on. We should be a team on amazing race together. I stand by that. I think we should. I think we, we would have been amazing. I think we would have been a total mess. Why?
然后珍娜，你还记得你当时怎么跟我说的吗，你说我们应该去参加。我们俩应该组个队去上《极速前进》。我至今依然这么觉得。我觉得我们真该去。我觉得我们俩一定能表现得超级棒。我觉得我们俩绝对会把节目搞得一团糟。为什么？
Why? Because I think you would be like, let's go, let's go. And I'd be like, can we just take a break? Maybe we'll have a glass of wine. You'd be like, yeah. Also, I can't eat any of that gross stuff, lady. I can't eat the gross stuff. Well, this is the problem.
为什么？因为我觉得你会一直说：“快走，快走，快走！”而我会说：“我们能不能歇一会儿？也许我们可以喝杯红酒？”然后你会说：“好吧。”而且，大姐，我都吃不下那些恶心的东西。我可吃不下那些恶心玩意儿。好吧，问题就在这儿。
I think we would both have some of the same weaknesses. I think we couldn't eat the gross stuff. And maybe neither one of us would have great upper body strength for some of the like things where you have to like, like toss bales of hay down a maze or something. How about zero upper body strength? Yeah. Like zero.
我觉得我们俩会有一些相同的弱点。我觉得我们都吃不下那些恶心食物。而且对于有些需要拼体力的项目，比如要把干草捆扔过一个迷宫什么的，我们俩可能谁也没有特别好的上肢力量。零上肢力量怎么样？对。就相当于零。
So maybe we wouldn't have been such a great team, but we would have had fun. I think we would have had fun. I think we would have had one colossal meltdown and then a fight. And then we would have cried and then we'd laugh hysterically. We'd look like like crazy people, but we would have had fun. I tell you what, we would have been good TV. Oh my God, we would have been great TV.
所以我们可能不会成为一个多好的团队，但我们一定会玩得很开心。我觉得我们绝对会玩得很开心。我觉得我们俩会彻底崩溃一次，然后大吵一架。接着我们会抱头痛哭，然后笑得前仰后合。我们看起来会像两个疯子，但我们一定会玩得很开心。我跟你打包票，我们绝对是很好的电视节目素材。天呐，我们绝对能贡献绝佳的电视效果。
Okay. Okay. Well, we actually asked Greg about this amazing race moment. And here's what he had to say. The comparison to amazing race was fun because it's a reality. We were a reality based comedy show. It was a lot easier for the visual look of the show to be able to try and do references to other reality shows rather
好吧。好吧。其实我们向格雷格问过关于《极速前进》这个梗的事。他是这么说的。把我们比作《极速前进》挺有意思的，因为这是一档真人秀。我们是一部以真人秀为基础的喜剧。对于本剧的视觉风格来说，尝试去致敬其他的真人秀节目，要比致敬……
than movies, for instance. So the, there's like a Titanic reference in booze cruise, but I don't think it, it works as visually well as a amazing race reference for, for here. Yeah. It totally makes sense to me though. I think Michael is such a fan of pop culture and television and film. Like he wants any opportunity for his documentary of this paper
电影容易得多，比如说。所以在《酒水游轮》里有一个《泰坦尼克号》的梗，但我认为它在视觉呈现上，不如《极速前进》的梗来得那么贴合、那么自然。对，不过这完全说得通。我觉得迈克尔就是流行文化、电视和电影的超级粉丝。他希望借任何机会，让记录这家纸业公司的纪录片团队——无论这到底是个啥——这个成天跟着他的摄像团队……
company, whatever this is, this camera crew that follows him around. He thinks he's on par with the entertainment of the day. Yes. Yes. Well, so now everyone gets in their cars and we kind of start driving around. And Angela, speaking of driving, we had a lot of questions about how we pulled off these driving shots.
觉得自己能跟当下的娱乐潮流平起平坐。没错。没错。好吧，现在大家都上车了，然后我们差不多开始开车上路了。安吉拉，说到开车，我们收到了很多关于这些车载镜头是怎么拍出来的问题。
Amy Jackson, Deandre Tessone, Holly E, T.J. McMillan, William Burke, and many more people all asked, how did filming work for the driving scenes? Are you guys actually driving or is there a green screen? What cameras were used in the car scenes and are the actors really driving around? Well, first of all, the actors really are driving around. That is not a green screen.
艾米·杰克逊、迪安德雷·特索内、霍莉·E、T·J·麦克米兰、威廉·伯克以及其他许多人都问过：开车场景到底是怎么拍摄的？你们是真在开车，还是用的绿幕？车内场景用的是什么摄像机，演员们真的在开车兜风吗？好吧，首先，演员们确实是在开车。那绝对不是绿幕。
And then we went to Greg and we asked him to talk a little bit about what it was like to shoot people in the cars. And here's what he had to say. One of the things I had noticed in production was how easy it was to shoot in a car for our show. You just basically put the two characters in the car and set up lipstick cameras and drove around and improvised a lot. And so the idea for traveling salesman was we could get a lot
然后我们去找格雷格，让他谈谈在车里拍演员是什么体验。他是这么说的。我在制作过程中注意到的一件事，就是在车里为我们剧拍摄是多么容易的一件事。你基本上只要把两个角色放进车里，安上口红摄像机，然后开车四处转，让他们即兴发挥就行了。所以《推销员出差》这一集的构想就是，通过离开办公室，我们可以获得很高的制作价值，而且对我们来说做起来也不会太难。我们只是把这些车改装了一下，然后它们就可以出发了。
of production value out of getting out of the office and it wouldn't be too hard for us to do. We just tricked out these cars and they would go off. So we have a little lingo alert there when Greg talks about lipstick cameras. Those are itty-bitty tiny cameras that they would put up in our visors in the car at an angle and one would shoot one passenger and one would shoot the other passenger.
所以当格雷格提到“口红摄像机”时，这就属于我们的行话小提醒了。那是一种微型到不行的超小摄像机，他们会以一定角度把它们安在我们车里的遮阳板上，一个摄像机拍一个乘客。
And we would just literally do what Greg said. We would just drive around and we would have a little walkie-talkie in the car. And there would be a car either in front of us or behind us that had the crew, the director, a sound person. They could hear us. They could see us on a little like mobile video screen. And they would talk to us over the walkie-talkie and they would
然后我们就会字面意义上照着格雷格说的去做。我们就开车四处兜风，车里会放一个对讲机。在我们的车前面或后面会跟着另一辆车，里面坐着剧组人员、导演和一个收音师。他们能听到我们说话。他们可以在一个小型的移动视频监视器上看到我们。他们会通过对讲机跟我们说话，他们会……
say, oh, that was great. We're going to do that again. And then we would just drive around. They would have police cars. Remember the police cars, Ange? Yeah, we had like the motorcycle police guys, too, who would sort of be in the front and we'd have this path that was cleared for us so that, you know, we wouldn't have to drive around
说，哦，刚才那条演得太棒了。我们再来一条。然后我们就继续开车。他们还会出动警车。安吉拉，你还记得那些警车吗？对，我们还有那种骑摩托的交警，他们会在前面开道，给我们清理出一条专用路线，这样呢，我们就……
people who didn't know we were filming, right? So it was safe. And we would just basically make a loop usually in one neighborhood. We'd just make the same loop over and over. Yeah, that was the whole thing that Kent Sabornac, aka Kentopedia, he would have to clear that. He'd have to call the highway patrol or the police and they
不用去应付那些不知道我们在拍戏的社会车辆了，对吧？这样很安全。而且我们通常基本上就在一个街区里兜圈子。我们就是一遍又一遍地开着同一条路线。对，肯·萨博纳克（Kent Sabornac，又名肯特百科全书）就是负责搞定这一整套的，他得去清空路段。他得打电话给高速巡警或当地警察，然后他们会……
would give us a zone that we were allowed to use for a certain period of time on that day. And we would just loop around. And it was always difficult in Los Angeles to find a loop that didn't have any palm trees. So we tend to film in the same neighborhoods over and over because clearly they found trees that looked possibly east coast ish, you know.
给我们划定一个区域，在当天的特定时间段内我们可以合法使用。我们就绕着这个圈子开。在洛杉矶，要想找到一个没有棕榈树的街区圈子总是很难。所以我们往往会在相同的街区反复拍摄，因为显然他们找到了那些看起来可能有点像美国东海岸风格的树，你知道的。
Yes. We got to know these loops very well. One of the things Dave Rogers said in the DVD commentary is that this was the first time that we used the lipstick cameras in the cars. Previously, when we had done driving scenes, one of our camera operators, Randall or Matt, would be scrunched in the backseat with a camera.
是的。我们对这些兜圈路线可以说是了如指掌。戴夫·罗杰斯在DVD评论音轨里提到的一点是，这是我们第一次在车里使用口红摄像机。此前，当我们拍摄开车场景时，我们的摄像师之一，兰德尔或者马特，会扛着摄像机缩在后座上。
And, you know, I noticed the video quality was a little different on the lipstick cameras when I was watching it. It's not quite as crisp as a Matt camera or a Randall camera. Look at you, Miss Techie. You got a tech alert there? I noticed it. I did. So let's talk about all of these cars and all they're driving
然后，你知道的，我在看剧的时候发现口红摄像机的视频画质有点不一样。它没有马特或兰德尔用摄像机拍出来的那么清晰。瞧瞧你，技术达人。你这是触发了技术小雷达吗？我注意到了。确实发现了。那我们来聊聊所有这些车以及他们在各处兜风的场景吧。
around. Well, the first scene we really see is Andy and Michael. And Andy is determined to use this one-on-one time with Michael to chip away at Dwight, right? He's going to undermine him. He asks about the laundry. Michael tells him that Dwight went to corporate to try to get his job. And, oh my gosh, Andy is like so happy to get this information.
好吧，我们看到的第一个场景其实是安迪和迈克尔。安迪决心利用这独处的时间来一点点瓦解德怀特在迈克尔心中的地位，对吧？他要暗中拆德怀特的台。他打听了洗衣服的事。迈克尔告诉他，德怀特曾去总公司试图取代他的职位。然后，天呐，安迪听到这个消息高兴坏了。
Yes. He's going to spend this whole episode slowly chipping away at Dwight's reputation. Yeah. Well, then we see Phyllis. She pulls into a beauty salon. Her and Karen are going to get some super glam makeovers. We don't know why.
没错。他要花一整集的时间慢慢瓦解德怀特的声誉。嗯。然后我们看到了菲莉丝。她把车开进了一家美容院。她和凯伦要去做个超华丽的造型大改造。我们不知道为什么。
It looks like when you used to go to the mall to glamour shots. Did you ever do that? I never did glamour shots, but my sister Emily did. Yes. I never did it either, but my sister Tina did. And they gave her this enormous hairdo, like this bouffant hairdo and all this makeup. And I think like a feather boa.
这看起来就像你以前去商场拍那种“写真照”的时候。你拍过吗？我从来没拍过写真照，但我妹妹埃米拍过。是的。我也从来没拍过，但我妹妹蒂娜拍过。他们给她弄了个巨大的发型，就像那种蓬松的高发型，还化了全妆。我想大概还戴了一条羽毛围巾吧。
That was common. That was common. And they would shoot you on a green screen and then sort of insert different backgrounds if I remember correctly. Like the Eiffel Tower. Yeah. Okay. So that is what this makeover looks like. That might be like an old tech alert.
这在当年很常见。这很常见。他们会让你站在绿幕前拍照，然后如果我没记错的话，再把不同的背景P上去。比如埃菲尔铁塔。没错。好吧，所以这次大改造看起来就是这个样子的。这可能算是个老旧的技术雷达了吧。
Does glamour shots still exist? I don't think so, lady. I don't think so. I think the era of the selfie and the iPhone, there aren't glamour. And the filters. And the filters. Glamour shots are no more. Well, then we also have Ryan and Stanley and Ryan asked Stanley
写真照现在还存在吗？我觉得没了，大姐。我觉得没有了。在这个自拍和iPhone的时代，已经没有写真了。还有滤镜。还有滤镜。写真照已经成为历史了。好吧，接着我们还有瑞恩和斯坦利，瑞恩问斯坦利……
if he could take the lead on the sales call. And Stanley is like, nothing would delight me more. Oh, Stanley knows something and he's tickled. He can't wait. Oh, can't wait. We will find out why in a little bit. So now back at the office while all this driving around is happening, Angela invites Pam to coffee.
他能不能在这次销售拜访中带头主导。斯坦利听了觉得：没有比这更让我高兴的了。哦，斯坦利心里有数，他觉得太逗了。他简直等不及了。哦，迫不及待。我们一会儿就会知道原因了。现在镜头回到办公室，就在外面到处兜风的同时，安吉拉邀请潘去喝咖啡。
Yes. And Pam was like, what? But okay. Now on a personal note, I was thrilled to do this scene. You and I never got to do scenes together, let alone go on a location together. We were giddy, Jenna. We couldn't wait.
对。潘当时一脸：啥？不过好吧。私底下说，我当时能拍这场戏真的超级激动。你和我从来没一起拍过戏，更不用说一起去外景地了。我们当时兴奋得像个小女孩，珍娜。我们简直迫不及待。
So some of that smiling and happiness you see in Angela Martin is just me being happy that I get to do a scene with my BFF. And I get to be normal. I get to smile and not be snarky. It was so, we were so excited, Angela, when we got this script. Yeah. All of my scenes are basically with you. Yeah.
所以你在安吉拉·马丁脸上看到的那些微笑和开心，其实就是我能和我的闺蜜一起拍戏的真实喜悦。而且我终于可以演个正常人了。我可以微笑了，不用刻薄了。安吉拉，拿到这个剧本的时候，我们真的太兴奋了。对啊。我所有的戏基本都跟你在一起。对。
We had the same work day and then we had a few days off. We were like, woohoo. It was kind of like BFF week. Yeah. For us. Well, some people pointed out that at the end of the scene, Pam grabs a notebook. And people were wondering, why is Pam bringing a notebook to
我们有相同的上班日，然后我们还有几天假期。我们当时一直在喊：呜呼！这简直就像是我们的闺蜜周。是的。对我们来说。好吧，有些人指出，在那个场景的结尾，潘拿了一个笔记本。
coffee? Is she going to take notes on Angela? No. No, you guys, there was a line that got cut out. Pam says to Angela, you know what? I'll go around and take some coffee orders. I'll see if anybody wants anything. Yes.
人们就在猜，潘去喝咖啡为什么要带个笔记本？她是要记下安吉拉的各种事吗？不。不，伙计们，其实有一句台词被剪掉了。潘对安吉拉说：“你知道吗？我去顺便帮大家记一下咖啡订单吧。我看看有没有人想要什么。”是的。
This is in the deleted scenes. She goes around. Meredith gets really angry at you. She's like, why would I pay $4 for milk and a cup? And she gets all angry. Her creed get real cranky, right? Yeah. They get real cranky about the fancy coffee orders.
这些在被删减片段里。她四处去问。梅雷迪思对你超级生气。她当时说：“我凭什么花4美元买牛奶和一个纸杯啊？”她气急败坏的。克里德他们是不是也超级难伺候，对吧？对。他们对这种花式咖啡订单超级挑剔。
And there is a scene, Jenna, that just won't break your heart because when we come back with a coffee, it's clear that Toby only ordered coffee so he could have some interaction with Pam. But when she comes back with all the coffees and she's passing them around, she just hands it to Kelly, who then takes it to Toby. And Toby just looks at Pam through the glass partition from the annex and he just, he just puts the coffee in the trash.
而且珍娜，有一个场景真的会让你心碎，因为当我们拿着咖啡回来时，很明显托尼订咖啡纯粹是为了能跟潘互动一下。但当她拿着所有咖啡回来并分发给大家时，她顺手递给了凯莉，然后凯莉把咖啡拿给了托尼。托尼隔着附楼的玻璃隔断看着潘，然后他……他直接把咖啡扔进垃圾桶了。
He didn't even get to talk to her. Aw, Toby. Poor Toby. Toby. So sad. Well, Ange, in the script, there is a scene where Pam is taking Toby's coffee order. Oh yeah, that's not in the deleted scenes.
他甚至都没机会跟她说话。啊，托尼。可怜的托尼。托尼。太惨了。不过安吉拉，剧本里其实有一场戏，讲的是潘帮托尼点咖啡。哦对，那段没在删减片段里。
Yeah. And he orders a chai latte and Pam says, oh my gosh, that's my coffee order. And he's like, oh, really? Oh, we have the same coffee order. Yeah. Aw. So not only does he not get his coffee delivered by Pam, he
对。他点了一杯柴乳拿铁，然后潘说：“天呐，这也是我的咖啡订单。”然后他惊讶地说：“哦，真的吗？我们的咖啡订单居然一样。”对。啊。所以他不仅没有喝到潘亲手送来的咖啡，他……
ordered a coffee he didn't even really drink just to have something in common with her. Toby. He's stalking Pam and in love with her. So now you guys, we're in the parking lot and Dwight wants to amp himself up. He's got to get pumped for this sales call. Jim knows they have been on countless sales calls.
点了一杯他其实根本不怎么喝的咖啡，只是为了能跟她有共同语言。托尼。他一直在暗恋潘，深爱着她。现在大家注意了，我们在停车场，德怀特想要给自己打打气。他必须为这次销售拜访做好心理建设。吉姆知道他们已经去过无数次销售拜访了。
He's like, you still do the thing. And Dwight's like, just give me the keys. And then he plays like, I don't know, is it like Motley Crew or something? And once again, we see Dwight like rocking out doing air guitar to heavy metal, like punching the seat to get ready. Yes. Yeah.
吉姆说：“你还在搞这一套。”德怀特说：“把车钥匙给我。”然后他放了一首，我不知道，是克鲁乐队（Motley Crue）的歌吗？然后我们再次看到德怀特像摇滚乐手一样，伴随着重金属音乐隔空弹吉他，还冲着座位挥拳来让自己进入状态。是的。对。
This is their, this is his routine, I guess. Yeah. And Jim knows it. They're like old roommates. He's like, here we go. I stand out here. He does air guitar. So he is amped up because then when they're walking into the
这就是他们的，这是他的常规流程吧。对。而且吉姆一清二楚。他们就像老室友一样。吉姆心想：来了来了。我站远点。他在那儿隔空弹吉他。所以他现在状态拉满了，因为等他们走进……
building, Dwight has to be Dwight and he's like, you go in first because he doesn't want to get attacked from behind. Seven out of 10 attacks are from the rear. Right. And Jim is like, well, what about the other 30% and Dwight's like, I'd block it. I'd block it. You can't get me.
大楼的时候，德怀特又开始了他的戏精上身，他说：“你先进去。”因为他不想遭到背袭。十分之七的袭击都是来自背后的。对。然后吉姆就问：“那另外的30%呢？”德怀特回答：“我会挡住的。我能挡住。你偷袭不了我。”
And then in like mid sentence, Jim just halls off and smacks Dwight and he is shocked. He can't believe he's been attacked from the front. He can't believe it. Also, he's about to break. Rain is about to laugh. You can totally see it at eight minutes, 50 seconds. Rain is about to laugh.
然后就在话音刚落的中途，吉姆直接抡起手一巴掌抽在德怀特脸上，德怀特整个人震惊了。他简直不敢相信自己居然是从正面遭到袭击的。他完全不敢相信。另外，他差点就要笑场了。雷恩差点就笑出来了。在分秒、秒时，你完全能看出来。雷恩快憋不住笑了。
Oh, 100%. 100%. Well, we had a fan question from Rachel Fortune. Was Jim supposed to slap Dwight as they walk in the building because rain looked truly shocked? Well, guys, this was a scripted moment. But there's a reason why rain was surprised even though it was scripted and we asked Greg about it.
哦，百分之百。百分之百。好吧，我们收到了来自瑞奇·福讯（Rachel Fortune）的粉丝提问：吉姆和德怀特走进大楼时，吉姆本来就打算扇德怀特耳光吗，因为雷恩看起来是真的震惊了？好吧，伙计们，这其实是剧本里写好的桥段。但雷恩之所以表现得那么惊讶，即使这是剧本安排的，其实是有原因的，我们问过格雷格。
Here's what he had to say. So some people asked about the Jim slapping Dwight moment. So, you know, it's fun to think of the two of them as being teamed up earlier in their career. And we gave it kind of an Abbott and Costello comedy team feel, you know, where Jim is like stopping short. So Dwight hits his head and usually these little moments involve some comeuppance for Dwight.
他是这么说的。所以有些人问到吉姆扇德怀特耳光的那个时刻。所以呢，把他们两个人在职业生涯早期就安排成搭档，这种设定挺有意思的。我们赋予了它一种“阿博特和科斯托洛”式的喜剧搭档感，你知道的，就是吉姆突然急刹停下。结果德怀特一头撞上去。通常这些小桥段都包含着对德怀特的一些恶人自有恶人磨的惩罚。
And I remember John came up to me right before we were going to shoot the part where he hits Dwight in the face. And he said that he wanted to hit rain for real a little bit harder than they had worked out just to get a good startle out of him. And I can't recall whether rain was in on this but just didn't want to know which take. But we kind of worked out which take he was going to do.
我记得就在我们要拍吉姆扇德怀特脸的那场戏之前，约翰走到我面前对我说，他想来真的，稍微比我们排练时打得重那么一点点，好让雷恩能演出那种真实的惊吓感。我不记得雷恩当时是不是知情了，但他大概只是不想知道具体是哪一条。不过我们商量好了约翰会在哪一条里动手。
And I'm pretty sure we used the one where rain was really startled that John had hit him. So here's the deal on the DVD commentary rain and John talk in depth about this moment. And rain asked John to hit him harder. He was like, I want you to hit me hard. And here's the thing about rain. He's very method, you guys.
而且我很确定我们最后用的就是那一条，因为雷恩对约翰真的打过来确实感到了实打实的惊吓。所以事情是这样的，在DVD评论音轨里，雷恩和约翰深入探讨了这个时刻。雷恩要求约翰打重一点。他说：“我要你狠狠地打我。”关于雷恩这个人是这样的，他演戏非常注重体验派，伙计们。
When I slapped him, remember in casino night. Yeah. He said to me, and you got to slap me harder. Really slapped me. So in the DVD commentary, John was like, remember rain? You were like, slap me harder. And I was like, okay. And of course that's the take they use because rain was
当年我扇他耳光的时候，还记得在赌场之夜那一集吗。对。他对我说：“你得扇得再重一点。真的用力扇我。”所以在DVD评论音轨里，约翰就说：“雷恩，你还记得吗？你当时说：‘扇我用力点！’”然后我说：“好吧。”当然，他们最后用了那一条，因为雷恩……
legitimately like, whoa. And then he almost started laughing. Well, you can totally tell that he was taken aback. Yeah. And it ends up making a scripted moment look unscripted. But it was definitely scripted. I remember it said something like Dwight gets smacked in the head by Jim.
确实被打得一脸懵：“哇哦。”然后他差点当场笑出来。好吧，你绝对能看出他是被打了个措手不及。对。这最终让一个剧本设定好的时刻看起来像即兴发挥。但它绝对是剧本里写好的。我记得上面写着类似“德怀特被吉姆狠狠扇了头部”这样的话。
And you know, we would always have stunt coordinators come in. Anytime we had to put our hands on another actor, even if it was something that might be considered small like a slap. And they actually teach you how to hit someone with your palm in this certain sort of cupped way. So it makes a louder noise or it looks more violent
而且你知道的，我们总是会有特技指导到现场。任何时候只要我们需要对另一个演员动手动脚，哪怕是像扇耳光这种看似很小的动作。他们其实会教你如何用掌心以某种特定的扣手方式去击打别人。这样能制造出更大的声音，或者看起来比实际更具暴力感。
than it really is. And so, you know, we always had that training in us as well. So I guess I should say rain was not hurt in the execution of this, but he was certainly shocked. Well, it worked and it cracked rain up and everyone else. And that's the take they picked. So lady, where are we? Are we going into some sales calls?
所以呢，你知道的，我们身上也总是带着这种训练基础。所以我想说的是，雷恩在完成这个镜头时并没有受伤，但他确实被结结实实地吓了一跳。好吧，效果确实很好，这把雷恩和其他所有人都逗乐了。这就是他们最终选中的那一镜。所以，大姐，我们现在到哪儿了？我们要去进行一些销售拜访了吗？
We are. We're about to go into all these sales meetings, but why don't we take a break and then we'll pick up right there in just a moment. Yeah. All right. We are back. Let's talk about all of these sales meetings.
是的。我们马上就要去这些销售会议了，不过我们为什么不先休息一下，然后过一会儿就在这里继续呢？好嘞。我们回来了。我们来聊聊所有这些销售会议吧。
Yes. I think the first one is Michael and Andy and Jenna. Once again, we see that Michael is a good salesman. He knows how to connect with people. He really does. He really does. He doesn't know how to be someone's boss. That is his failing.
好。我觉得第一场是迈克尔和安迪的，珍娜。我们再次看到，迈克尔其实是个出色的推销员。他知道如何与人建立联系。他真的很有一套。他确实可以。他只是不知道怎么当别人的老板。那是他的致命弱点。
He thinks that he's supposed to entertain you as a boss, but he does know how to connect with people one on one. And he really connects with this guy over fishing. He compliments the fish that he caught. And it's a callback to Lake Wallam Pawpack. Love a callback. Love a callback. And then Andy's like, yeah, my dad has a Bayliner,
他以为当老板就得负责娱乐大家，但他确实很懂得如何与别人进行一对一的交流。他通过钓鱼这个话题和这个客户聊得非常投机。他称赞了客户钓到的那条鱼。这是在呼应沃兰帕帕克湖（Lake Wallam Pawpack）那一集。太喜欢这种呼应了。超爱这种呼应。然后安迪就说：“对呀，我爸有一艘拜莱纳（Bayliner）游艇……”不管他说的是什么。
whatever he says. I shot a shark. I mean, if you were a true fisherman, the idea of shooting a fish in any way is so off-putting. There's sort of an art to fishing and a lot of people even do like the throwback, you know, if they're fishing on a lake. So you could just tell this really was off-putting to this man. Angela, do you know all of that because of your ex-boyfriend
“我还射杀过一条鲨鱼。”我的天，如果你是个真正的渔夫，任何形式的“射鱼”想法都会让人超级反感。钓鱼本身是有一定艺术性的，很多人甚至会采取“放归”（throwback）的做法，特别是当他们在湖里钓鱼的时候。所以你能看出，这话确实把这个男人给恶心到了。安吉拉，你对这些这么懂，全是因为那个逼你去看《全美垂钓大赛》（Bassmasters）的前男友吗？
that made you watch Bassmasters? Oh, God, you had to bring up. I want to tell you, Angela, after we talked about Bassmasters on the podcast, they sent us each a little goodie bag of stuff and one of the things that they sent us, it was so sweet. They just said, hey, thanks for talking about us. It was totally organic and random, but they sent me this journal. A leather bound journal.
哦，天哪，你非得提这事。安吉拉，我得告诉你，我们在播客里聊过《全美垂钓大赛》之后，他们竟然给我们俩每人寄了一个装着周边的小礼包。其中一样东西送得太贴心了。他们就说：“嘿，谢谢你们聊起我们。这完全是自发且随机的，但我还是想给你寄一本这个笔记本。”一本精装皮面笔记本。
It's so nice. A leather bound journal that says Bassmasters on it. And I love it. It is my new favorite journal. So now because of your ex-boyfriend making you watch Bassmasters and you bringing it up on this podcast, I now journal in a Bassmasters journal. That is what has happened.
太精美了。一本印着《全美垂钓大赛》字样的精装皮面笔记本。我太喜欢它了。它成了我最爱的新笔记本。所以，因为你的前男友逼你看《全美垂钓大赛》，又因为你在播客里提到了它，我现在的日常手账居然是用一本《全美垂钓大赛》的笔记本写的。这就是事情的真相。
Well, you're welcome. And Kyle says you're welcome. That was his name. Well, thank you, Kyle. Oh, no. It's out there. Oh, boy. Yeah.
好吧，不客气。凯尔也会对你说不客气。那家伙就叫这名。好吧，谢谢你，凯尔。哦，不。这秘密曝光了。天哪。对。
Well, Bassmasters sent me a hoodie that I love, and I walk around with my Bassmasters hoodie. Yeah. So here's the thing. There's a great little moment in the DVD commentary about this scene where Ed says that he and Steve did go off script in this scene. And the actor that plays the business owner they're talking to was not really ready for them to go off script.
好吧，《全美垂钓大赛》还寄给我一件我超级喜欢的连帽衫，我平时穿着我的《全美垂钓大赛》连帽衫到处走。对。所以重点是这样的。在DVD评论音轨里有一个关于这个场景的精彩小片段，埃德在里面说，他和史蒂夫在这个场景里确实脱稿即兴发挥了。而且他们正在交谈的那个饰演企业主的演员，其实并没有准备好让他们脱稿。
He wasn't. Oh, dear. And he just gave them this sort of odd, quizzical look. Like, what are you talking about? And Dave Rogers is in this commentary and he goes, but it was perfect. Look, you see this man giving Michael and Andy, like, what? Is really earnest.
他完全没有防备。哦，天呐。然后他给了他们那种怪异、充满疑惑的表情。就像在说：你们在胡说八道些什么？然后戴夫·罗杰斯在评论音轨里就说：“但效果太完美了。看，你瞧这老哥给迈克尔和安迪的那种眼神，像是在说‘啥？’。那表情太真诚了。”
Oh, my gosh. I love that. I love that tidbit. Well, guys, the actor who plays the client that Michael and Andy are talking to is named Warren Sweeney. So, Warren, while you were surprised, your look worked. It totally worked. Well, then we cut to the car.
哦，天呐。我太爱这个了。我太喜欢这个花絮了。好吧，伙计们，饰演迈克尔和安迪正在交谈的那个客户的演员名叫沃伦·斯维尼（Warren Sweeney）。所以，沃伦，虽然你当时很惊讶，但你的表情效果拔群。简直神了。然后画面切到了车里。
And you can tell Michael is not pleased with Andy, but Andy turns it around. And he's like, I'm so sorry for screwing up our sales call. I really shrewd it. Yeah. That's what we say around the office when someone really screws up. We say they shrewd it.
你能看出迈克尔对安迪很不满，但安迪马上把话锋转了回来。他说：“真对不起，搞砸了我们的销售拜访。我把它‘欧’（shrewd）砸了。”对。这就是我们在办公室里当有人把事情彻底搞砸时会说的话。我们说他们把事情给“欧”了。
And then he's like, I wonder how that name came up. I wonder if it's because of Dwight. And Michael gives him nothing. Michael's like, well, who knows how words are formed. Like, he's not getting it, and Andy's getting so frustrated. Andy is planting all these seeds that Dwight is an idiot, and Michael is not getting it. It's awesome.
然后他又说：“我在想这个词是怎么来的。我猜是不是因为德怀特。”而迈克尔完全没接这茬。迈克尔说：“谁知道这些词是怎么来的呢。”他根本没往那方面想，而安迪急得要命。安迪一直在暗中埋下各种雷，暗示德怀特是个白痴，但迈克尔压根没get到。这太绝了。
So let's now talk about Phyllis and Karen's meeting. They get a very large order from this gentleman. Oh, this is my St. Louis catch. All right. This is around 11. Oh, OK. This is around 11 minutes, 33 seconds. And Phyllis goes, well, thanks.
那我们现在来聊聊菲莉丝和凯伦的会议。他们从这位先生那里拿到了一个非常大额的订单。哦，这就是我的圣路易斯大丰收。好吧。这大概在11分钟……哦，好的。大约在11分33秒。然后菲莉丝说：“哦，谢谢。这可是个大订单（order）。”她没说order。她说的是“大订单”（odeur，口误发音）。对，这跟Fark发音简直绝配。哦，圣路易斯大丰收。
That's a big order. She doesn't say order. That's a big order. It says, like, order. Yeah, that's right in line with Fark. Oh, St. Louis catch. And then she asks how his wife is doing. And he shows a photo of himself and his wife on vacation.
然后她问他太太近况如何。接着他展示了一张自己和妻子在度假时的照片。结果照片里的人长得跟他一模一样。同样的头发，同样的妆容。凯伦就心想：啊，我懂你在玩什么把戏了。非常聪明。好啦。我们得聊聊德怀特和吉姆的销售拜访，因为珍娜，他们俩显然有一套烂熟于心的默契老把戏。
And they look just like her. The same hair, the same makeup. And Karen's like, ah, I see what you're doing. Very smart. OK. We've got to talk about Dwight and Jim in their sales call, because Jenna, they clearly have a whole shtick. Yes.
我太喜欢了。配合得天衣无缝。对。我跟你说，当德怀特在打电话，念着“七，三……”时，我孩子们笑得前仰后合，我们当时在狂笑。好吧，安吉拉，我不知道你怎么样，但我超级讨厌那种机器人客服热线……
I loved it. It's so seamless. Yes. I want you to know my kids left so hard when Dwight, when he's making the call, and he's going seven, three, if we're cracking up. Well, I don't know about you, Angela, but I hate those, like, robocall customer service lines
以至于每当它们跳出来时，我就会立刻说：“人工客服！转人工，转接人工服务，人工！”我甚至连数字都不想按。我真的受不了。安吉拉，我对爸爸有着极其美好的回忆。很奇妙，你知道的，当你深爱的人离世时，我并不是想在这里制造什么悲伤的情绪……
so much that I just, like, immediately when they come up, I'm like, agent, speak to a, speak to pharmacist, agent. I won't even say any numbers. I'm like, I can't. I can't. Jenna, I have such a fond memory of my dad. It's weird, you know, when you, when someone you love so much passes away, and I don't mean to be a Debbie Downer here
在这个时刻，因为这对我来说是一个快乐的回忆，但有趣的是，你的大脑会紧紧抓住并珍视那些你永远、永远意想不到的事情。我脑海里有一个极其生动的记忆，就是我爸爸在电话里显然在跟某种机器人对话。他这个人，你知道的，他曾经只是个温和的牛仔，一个南方老哥，他当时一直在按：“五。五。
in this moment, because this is a happy memory for me, but it's interesting that things your brain latches onto and holds dear, things you would never, ever expect. But I have such a vivid memory of my dad on the phone with clearly, like, some kind of, like, robot. And he's, he's this, you know, he was just this sweet cowboy, you know, Southern guy, and he was going five. Five.
不。对。跟人通话。人。是不是不管密码是什么都行？拖拉机。拖拉机。哦，我好喜欢这个记忆，伊恩。
No. Yes. Talk to person. Person. Is it like whatever the password was? Tractor. Tractor. Oh, I love that, Ian.
我太喜欢了。你分享了这个。这让我想起了他。这很奇妙。你的大脑运作的方式真的很奇妙。你的大脑和你的心。对。好吧，所以，对，德怀特正在打这个电话。
I love it. You shared that. It made me think of him. It's weird. It's weird the way your brain works like that. Your brain and your heart. Yeah. Okay, so, yeah, so Dwight is doing this call.
我们不知道他在给谁打，而吉姆则在一旁继续他的销售陈词，对吧？对，在这一片混乱中。然后客户说：“听着，我不知道该说什么。就是……我可能跟大公司合作会觉得更踏心一点，跟那些行业巨头合作。”然后他们就说：“哦，那客户服务对你重要吗？”客户说：“非常重要。”
We don't know who he's calling, and Jim presses on with his sales pitch, right? Yeah, through all of this. And the guy is like, listen, I don't know what to tell you. I mean, I just maybe feel more comfortable with the, with a bigger company, with one of the big guys. And they're like, well, is customer service important to you? And he's like, it's very important.
然后吉姆说：“哦，那我们刚才正好一直在各大公司的客服部门苦苦等待呢。”哦，反转来了。哈。原来这是他们俩设好的局。然后吉姆拨通了邓德米夫林的客服热线，接电话的是凯莉。当时我就想：嘿，你们俩在干嘛呢？
And he's like, well, we've been on hold with the customer service department of a big company. Oh, and there's the switch. Aha. There was a whole purpose. And then he calls Dunder Mifflin customer service and Kelly answers. I was like, hey, what are you guys doing?
没错。太绝了。然后客户当场就决定：买下。买下了。我要把业务交给你们。买单。接着德怀特递上了他的名片。
Yes. Yes. So amazing. And then the guy is like sold. Sold. I'll give you my business. Sold. And Dwight hands him his business card.
珍娜，我太喜欢德怀特名片上的内容了。他的手机号、寻呼机号、家里电话，还有他的另一个寻呼机号。对。然后他说：“我没有休假。我从来没生过病，我不过任何重大节日。”然后客户说：“行了行了，我知道了。”有趣的技术雷达。
And Jenna, I love what's on Dwight's business card. His cell number, his pager number, his home number, and his other pager number. Yeah. And then he says, I take no days off. I've never been sick and I don't celebrate any major holidays. And he's like, okay, okay, I got it. Interesting tech alert.
他的名片上居然没有邮箱地址，珍娜。哈。现在的话，我觉得上面肯定会印邮箱的。绝对会的。绝对的。但我们拍这集的时候可是在石器时代。现在瑞恩和斯坦利走进了教堂去进行他们的销售拜访。这四位年纪较长、看起来非常有尊严的黑人男士……
His email was not on his business card, Jenna. Huh. Nowadays, I think your email would be on there. For sure. For sure. But we shot this in the Stone Age. So now Ryan and Stanley go into the church for their sales call. And these four older, very sort of like dignified black men and
穿着西装朝他们走来。他们显然是老一代的人。那是斯坦利同龄的人。其中还有一个年轻的白人小伙，珍娜，我觉得，我觉得瑞恩已经好久没进过教堂了吧。没有。而且我们已经确定了，所有这些销售拜访能成功的秘诀，全在于人们通过某种……
their suits walk out to him. They're clearly an older generation. They're Stanley's generation. And there's this young white kid who Jenna, I don't think, I don't think Ryan's been in the church in a while. No. And we've established that the way all these sales calls are successful is by people connecting with their client in some
个人方式与客户建立联系。我们很快发现，瑞恩将很难与这几位老绅士建立联系。他开始结结巴巴，并且不停地一遍又一遍地自我介绍。嗨。嗨。嗨。
personal way. And we quickly see that Ryan is going to have a hard time connecting with these gentlemen. And he just sort of starts stammering and he just keeps introducing himself over and over again. Hi. Hi. Hi.
嗨。我太喜欢斯坦利那种态度了，他说：“伙计，我可不帮你。事实上，我要无视你。我要转过身去玩我的纵横字谜，让你自生自灭——”那个词怎么说来着？随风飘零。任由你在风中凌乱。对。
Hi. And I love that Stanley's like, man, I'm not helping you. In fact, I'm just going to ignore you. I'm going to turn away and do my crossword and let you just, what's the expression to nowhere? Just you flap in the wind. Blow in the wind. Yeah.
差不多就是这样。他打算直接把瑞恩晾在那儿不管了。太精彩了。我设法查到了其中两位客户的名字，但我没能找到其他几个人的名字。兰登·H·刘易斯二世（Landon H. Lewis Jr.）和莱昂·西蒙斯二世（Leon Simmons Jr.）是那场戏里其中的两位客户。我也很喜欢那场戏里所有男士的身高都比BJ高出那么多。
Something like that. He's just going to hang him out to dry there. It's so good. I was able to find out the names of two of the clients, but I couldn't find names for the other guys, but Landon H. Lewis Jr. and Leon Simmons Jr. are two of the clients in that scene. I also loved how all of the men in the scene were so much
对。因为这确实也衬托得他看起来太年轻了，你知道吗？对。而且我觉得这纯粹是身高差带来的喜感。对。然后后来他们在车里的时候，安吉拉……
taller than BJ. Yes. Because it really also made him just look so young, you know? Yeah. And I think that's just the size difference. Yes. And then later when they're in the car, Angela,
斯坦利笑得根本停不下来。有很多镜头都切回到他们开车返回邓德米夫林的路上。斯坦利简直就是：简直不敢相信，他对刚才那过程感到无比开心。他觉得太逗了。那显然让他度过了极为开心的一天。我不知道斯坦利在邓德米夫林工作能获得多少乐趣，但这次经历绝对是他职业生涯的一个高光时刻。
Stanley cannot stop laughing. There are all these shots that go back to them driving back to Dunder Mifflin. And Stanley is just like, can't believe, he's so delighted by how that went. He's so tickled. It clearly made his day. I don't know that Stanley gets much joy out of working at
而且莱斯利（Leslie）在DVD花絮里谈到了这个时刻。他说在剧本里，原本只写了斯坦利在开车并且在笑，然后他们就顺其自然让他自由发挥了。他即兴发挥了后面整段台词：“嗨，嗨，你听起来就像我六个月大的小侄女。”诸如此类的话全都是莱斯利即兴现挂的。哦，太棒了。
Dunder Mifflin, but this was a real highlight for him. And there's this moment that Leslie talks about in the DVD. He said in the script, it was just that Stanley is driving and laughing, and they just kind of let him go. And he improvised the whole thing about, hi, hi, you sounded like my six-month-old niece. And like all of that, Leslie was just riffing. Oh, that was so good.
我懂。他说，事实上，每当斯坦利像整部剧里那样开始数落瑞恩时，他们都会让莱斯利放飞自我。我觉得这里面有很多绝妙的高光时刻。哦，没错。没错。好吧，你知道的，这是瑞恩的第二次销售拜访了……
I know. And he said, in fact, whenever Stanley would go off on Ryan, as he has throughout the show, they would just let Leslie just go. And I think there's some amazing moments. Oh, yes. Yes. Well, you know, and this is Ryan's second sales call now
结果都不太顺利。还记得他跟德怀特一起去的那次入职新人销售拜访吗。他们根本没拉到单。现在他又和斯坦利一起出来拜访。不过我相信斯坦利这次肯定能把单谈成。哦，斯坦利绝对力挽狂澜了。好吧。就在所有这些销售会议进行的同时，
that has not gone well. Remember, he went on the initiation sales call with Dwight. They did not make the sale. And now he's gone out on this call with Stanley. Now, I believe Stanley is going to save the sale. Oh, Stanley for sure saved it. Okay. So while all of these sales meetings are happening,
潘和安吉拉正在咖啡馆里。安吉拉的心情好极了，她正在跟潘讲一个故事：她有个朋友当时遇到了困难，然后有一个英勇的男士挺身而出拯救了她。对。她接着说：“他一定非常关心她，因为他为我的朋友做了这么一件了不起的事。”对。
Pam and Angela are at the coffee shop. Angela is in such a great mood and she's telling Pam a story about how she had this friend who was in need and this gallant man came to her rescue. Yeah. She's like, he must really care for her a lot because he did this wonderful thing for my friend. Yeah.
她在说暗号。她在用代号说话。她说：“我的朋友，我们叫她诺埃尔（Noelle）吧。这位英勇的绅士，我们就叫他库尔特（Kurt）吧。”好吧，我们都知道库尔特是德怀特的中间名，对吧？是的。我们为此收到了很多粉丝提问，安吉拉。肯茜·B、伊丽莎白·R、朱莉娅·李、妮可·芬克和凯蒂·克罗……
She's talking in code. She's speaking in code. She's like, my friend, let's call her Noelle. And this gallant gentleman will call him Kurt. Well, we all know that Kurt is Dwight's middle name, right? Yes. And we got a lot of fan questions about this, Angela. Kenzie B., Elizabeth R., Julia Lee, Nicole Fink, and Katie Kroll
都想知道，当安吉拉提到她的朋友诺埃尔时，是不是因为诺埃尔其实是安吉拉的中间名？听起来确实非常符合安吉拉·马丁中间名的风格。好吧，是的，这确实是安吉拉的中间名。安吉拉自以为自己做得天衣无缝、聪明绝顶，但潘完全知道她在说谁。没错，那就是她的中间名。不过珍娜，我有个问题要问你。
all want to know when Angela refers to her friend Noelle, is that because Noelle is Angela's middle name? It definitely sounds like a very Angela Martin middle name. Well, yes, it is Angela's middle name. Angela thinks she's being really savvy, but Pam totally knows who she's talking about. But yes, that is her middle name. But Jenna, I have a question for you.
好。诺埃尔这个名字在剧本里吗？因为我关于这个中间名还有一个小故事，我挺好奇的，我记得剧本里写的其实是科莱特（Colette）。好。我查过这个。在剧本里，安吉拉其实是这样说的。她说：“嗯，我有个朋友，我们姑且叫她……
Okay. Is Noelle in the script? Because I have a little story about that middle name and I'm curious, I think what was in the script was Colette. Okay. I looked this up. And in the script, Angela actually says this. She says, well, a friend of mine, let's just call her,
哦，我们姑且叫她‘我’吧。”然后你咯咯笑了起来。好吧。我对这段的记忆是，当时我们在拍那场戏时，编剧们一直在向我抛出不同的中间名选项，让我说不同的名字。我知道其中一个选项是科莱特。
oh, let's just call her me. What? And then you giggle. Okay. So my memory of this is when we were shooting it that day that the writers were pitching me different middle names, like different things to say. I know in one of them it was Colette.
我对说那个名字记忆犹新。然后我们改成了诺埃尔。我最喜欢诺埃尔，因为它听起来非常符合安吉拉·马丁的调性，不是吗？她对圣诞节的热爱，对圣诞故事的热爱，使得“诺埃尔”这个词作为她的中间名再合适不过了。这就是我们最终选定的名字。戴夫·罗杰斯在DVD评论音轨里也谈到了这一点，他说……
I have such a memory of saying that. And then we said Noelle. And I like Noelle the best because it sounds very sort of Angela Martin, doesn't it? Her love of Christmas, her love of the story of Christmas that Noelle would be her middle name. And that's the one we went with. Dave Rogers talks about it in the DVD commentary and he goes,
我太记得当时说这话的情景了。然后我们说叫诺埃尔（Noelle）。我最喜欢诺埃尔，因为它听起来非常像安吉拉·马丁（Angela Martin）的风格，对吧？她对圣诞节的热爱，对圣诞节故事的热爱，使得诺埃尔成了她的中间名。这就是我们最终选定的名字。戴夫·罗杰斯（Dave Rogers）在DVD评论中谈到了这一点，他说：
I remember it being Colette. And he thought maybe I improvised Noelle, but I didn't. That was a writer's pitch. I mean, I think I was part of the dialogue. I think we were pitching names, but that all sort of happened in the moment. I love it. It's perfect.
我记得是科莱特。而且他以为诺埃尔是我即兴发挥的，但其实不是。那是编剧提出的点子。我是说，我觉得我有参与台词创作。我想我们在商量名字，但这一切都是顺其自然发生的。我喜欢。太完美了。
It is perfect. Angela Noelle Martin. And I believe that will appear on your wedding invitation. Oh, yeah. It's now part of my character's show Bible. We had another fan catch in this scene, Angela. Sarah Rouse wrote in to say Pam is holding a piece of paper at the coffee shop.
确实完美。安吉拉·诺埃尔·马丁。我相信这个名字会出现在你的婚礼请柬上。哦，对啊。它现在已经成我角色官方资料设定集的一部分了。安吉拉，这场戏里我们还有另一个被粉丝发现的细节。萨拉·罗斯写信说，帕姆在咖啡店里拿了一张纸。
What is that supposed to be? And what does it say? Well, Sarah, that was the list of coffee orders from those deleted scenes. I had all the coffee orders written down on that piece of paper and I was going to use it to make my order. Well, Angela, also in this scene, just because we were talking about it earlier,
那是什么东西？上面写了什么？好吧，萨拉，那是那些被删减片段里咖啡订单的单子。我把所有的咖啡订单都写在那张纸上了，我打算用它来点我的咖啡。好吧，安吉拉，同样在这场戏里，因为我们刚才聊到了，
your flower hairdo is on full display. Just if you really want some great shots of it, guys, here it is, her WTF hairdo right here. WTF. Well, wait, wait. I have something to share. So while we were on a break, I had been texting Kim Ferry about this hair and she texted back.
你的花朵发型一览无余。伙计们，如果你真的想要一些特写镜头的话，看这里，她那个WTF发型就在这。WTF。等等，等等。我有东西要分享。所以就在我们休息的时候，我一直在给金·费里发短信讨论这个发型，然后她回信了。
And so this is what she had to say about it. Oh my gosh, it's a real-time tidbit. It's a real-time tidbit. It just came in a few minutes ago. I said, Kim, what was the inspiration for this bun? I mean, I know that we thought my character was going to, like, be in a great mood and so we wanted to try something new. She said, yes, here is the inspiration.
她就是这么说的。哦天哪，这是一个实时的猛料。这是一个实时的猛料。就在几分钟前刚发来的。我说，金，这个发髻的灵感是什么？我是说，我知道我们当时觉得我的角色会心情很好，所以我们想尝试一些新东西。她说，是的，灵感就在这里。
She said, my first job in the business was working on a sci-fi show called Babylon 5. I worked on this show for five years and I couldn't use any contemporary hairstyles because they wanted the hairstyles to look futuristic. So I started coming up with all these different kind of braids and buns with wires and fancy updos and zulu knots, basically anything different
她说，我在这个行业的第一份工作是参与一部叫《巴比伦5号》的科幻剧。我在这个节目工作了五年，我不能使用任何当代的发型，因为他们希望发型看起来有未来感。所以我开始设计各种不同的辫子、发髻，带电线的、华丽的盘发以及祖鲁结，基本上只要是我能想到的任何不同的东西
that I could think of. And your bun with those fun swirls was a good one for me because I had done it on Babylon 5. It's fast and easy, but technically, this is a sci-fi hairstyle. Oh, my gosh. Isn't that great? Don't you feel like Dwight would have loved it
我都能设计出来。你那个带有有趣旋涡的发髻对我来说是个不错的选择，因为我在《巴比伦5号》里做过这个。它又快又简单，但严格来说，这是一个科幻发型。哦，天哪。是不是很棒？你不觉得德怀特会超级喜欢它吗？
because he was Mr. Sci-Fi? Yes. Yes, no wonder she did her hair in this Babylon 5 hairstyle to thank Dwight for his, like, favor. Yeah, so yes, this hairstyle inspired by Babylon 5. It's the sci-fi bun. I don't think I could love that more. Kim Ferry, thank you for the real-time tidbit.
因为他是科幻迷？对啊。没错，难怪她要做这个《巴比伦5号》的发型来感谢德怀特的某种人情。对，所以没错，这个发型灵感来自《巴比伦5号》。这就是科幻发髻。我想我再怎么喜欢它都不为过。金·费里，谢谢你的实时猛料。
Thank you, Kim Ferry. Sam just wrote, Beats, Bears, Babylon 5. Beats, oh wait, here we go. Bears, Beats, Babylon 5 buns. Oh, okay, so now everybody is coming back from their sales calls. Everyone's done. And we have this amazing scene in the car
谢谢你，金·费里。萨姆刚刚写道，威士忌、熊、《巴比伦5号》。威士忌，哦等等，来了。熊、威士忌、《巴比伦5号》发髻。哦，好吧，现在每个人都从推销电话那里回来了。大家都搞定了。我们在车里还有一场精彩绝伦的戏，
with Karen and Phyllis. Phyllis is so good in this scene because you guys, she is going to reveal such a big plot point and she just throws it away, right? It's not, like, belabored in any way. It's so perfect. Yeah, she's like, Karen, I had a lot of fun with you today. I really enjoy spending time with you.
有凯伦和菲利斯。菲利斯在这场戏里演得太好了，因为伙计们，她即将透露一个如此重大的剧情点，而她就那么轻描淡写地抛出来了，对吧？一点也不显得刻意。太完美了。对，她就像是，凯伦，我今天和你在一起玩得很开心。我很享受和你在一起的时光。
They're bonding. They feel good. And then she just very offhandedly says, and I'm really glad you're with Jim. That makes me really happy because, you know, he was really hung up on Pam for such a long time. And she's not even looking at Karen. She's looking in a review mirror.
她们在建立感情。她们感觉很好。然后她就非常随口地说了一句，我真的很高兴你和吉姆在一起。这让我觉得特别开心，因为，你知道的，他一直对帕姆念念不忘好长一段时间。而且她甚至都没看着凯伦。她看着后视镜。
She's turning. She's just driving. She's sort of saying something off the cuff and it's that much more powerful. And then Rashida, oh my gosh, her reaction is so perfect. It's a fantastic scene, fantastic scene. I feel like her pulse stops for a second.
她在转弯。她只是在开车，顺口说出了这样一句话，而这却充满了力量。然后拉什达，哦天哪，她的反应太完美了。这是一场极棒的戏，极棒的戏。我觉得她的脉搏停了一秒钟。
Like, I feel like I can see the wind go out of her, right? Yeah. Yes, I do too. You just, you see it hit her like a freight train, but she can't react. Yeah, the way it's really hitting her. It's so well done. These ladies did such a great job.
就像，我觉得我能看到她的气势一下子泄了，对吧？对。是的，我也这么觉得。你就是，你能看到这像一列货运列车一样撞击了她，但她却无法做出反应。是的，这种真正冲击到她的方式。做得太好了。这些女士们表现得太棒了。
I agree. Yes. Well, Andy is the first person to actually get back to the office. And he starts sneaking around Dwight's desk. He goes through his car. Yeah, Andy is a total snake. I mean, what the heck?
我同意。是的。好了，安迪是第一个真正回到办公室的人。他开始在德怀特的办公桌周围鬼鬼祟祟的。他搜了德怀特的车。对，安迪就是个彻头彻尾的卑鄙小人。我是说，搞什么鬼？
I know. And he finds this toll booth receipt that proves that Dwight was in New York this morning. He didn't oversleep like he claimed, and he marches into Michael's office and he's like, I found this toll booth receipt. I wonder what he was doing. Was he, maybe he was talking to Jan.
我懂。然后他发现了一张收费站收据，证明德怀特今天早上在纽约。他并没有像自己声称的那样睡过头，他大步走进迈克尔的办公室说，我找到了这张收费站收据。我不知道他在干嘛。他在，也许他在和简说话。
And then he says like, I seem to kind of remember, I don't know who told me this, even though Jenna, this was like, like an hour ago. He's like, I don't know who told me this. It was something. And then he has maybe one of my favorite quotes of this episode. He was like, there's a story, I don't know. It was about laundry and betrayal.
然后他说，我好像有点记不清了，我不知道是谁告诉我的，尽管詹娜，这就像是，一个小时前的事。他说，我不知道是谁告诉我的。就是那么回事。然后他可能说出了我在这集里最喜欢的台词之一。他说，有个故事，我也不知道。那是关于洗涤和背叛的。
In my mind, this is now a lifetime movie called Laundry and Betrayal. I want to see it. Yes. Yes. Laundry and Betrayal, I want to see this film. I do too. Well, so Michael calls Jan.
在我看来，这现在成了一部名为《洗涤与背叛》的终身频道电影。我想看。没错。没错，《洗涤与背叛》，我想看这部电影。我也想看。好吧，于是迈克尔给简打了电话。
And Jan is like, well, I didn't speak to Dwight, but he did not give a reason for why he was here. Yes. This is my kid's favorite part. My kid's favorite part is Jan goes, he did sign into the security sign-in sheet, but under state your business, he wrote beeswax, not yours incorporated. I love that too.
简就说，嗯，我没有和德怀特说话，但他没有说明他为什么来这里。没错。这是我孩子最喜欢的部分。我孩子最喜欢的部分是简说，他在保安签到表上签了名，但在“办什么事”一栏，他写的是“关你屁事，无可奉告公司”。我也超喜欢那个。
My kids loved that. Well, when Dwight gets back to the office, Michael confronts him. He's like, where were you? Tell me where you were. And Dwight will not say. He won't say where he was. He overslept. The damn rooster didn't crow.
我孩子们可喜欢了。好吧，当德怀特回到办公室时，迈克尔质问他。他质问说，你去了哪里？告诉我你去了哪里。而德怀特死活不说。他就是不说他去了哪里。他睡过头了。该死的公鸡没打鸣。
Yeah. But he will not, um, he will not fess up. And this becomes a problem. And Pam knows why. Pam and Angela are exchanging looks. Angela is sweating it. She's horrified that Dwight's going through this, but she doesn't want people to know about them.
对。但他就是不肯，嗯，他就是不肯招认。这就成了一个问题。而帕姆知道原因。帕姆和安吉拉在交换眼神。安吉拉急得直冒汗。她对德怀特经历这一切感到惊恐万分，但她不想让别人知道他们的关系。
It's very layered emotionally for Angela. Well, it leads to a break room scene with Dwight and Angela, where you are, again, not facing one another. One of your famous, famous break room scenes. There's a little bit of heartbreak in the break room in this scene. Oh, lady, I noticed it too. Here's what we had. My mama needed me.
对安吉拉来说，这在情感上很有层次感。好吧，这引发了茶水间里德怀特和安吉拉的一场戏，你们俩，再次地，没有面对面。你们那些著名的、著名的茶水间戏码之一。这场戏里茶水间带有一点点心碎。哦，天哪，我也注意到了。这是我们听到的：我妈妈需要我。
A sexy sweater. I thought my life would get so much better. But all I got that afternoon was heartbreak in the break room. That was by Michelle Ferguson. Michelle, you know how much we love that song. We love it. Yeah.
一件性感的毛衣。我以为我的生活会变得好得多。但我那天下午得到的只有茶水间里的心碎。那是米歇尔·弗格森写的。米歇尔，你知道我们有多喜欢那首歌。我们太喜欢了。对。
Michelle, I literally listen to it all the time. It's super catchy. It's very catchy. I really love it. Someone give this woman a music contract. We'll buy it. Okay. We love it.
米歇尔，我真的无时无刻不在听。它超级洗脑。非常洗脑。我真的很喜欢。谁给这位女士一份音乐合同吧。我们会买的。好的。我们太爱了。
Yeah. So Dwight is like, listen, why don't we just come clean and, you know, let people know our love for one another. So this scene actually went on. It's not in the deleted scenes, but we did shoot a little bit longer of a version where as I cry behind me, Dwight's like, don't cry, monkey. Monkeys, don't cry.
对啊。所以德怀特就说，听着，为什么我们不直接坦白，然后，你知道的，让大家知道我们对彼此的爱。所以这场戏其实还有后续。它不在删除片段里，但我们确实拍了一个稍微长一点的版本，当我在身后哭泣时，德怀特说，别哭，小猴子。小猴子，别哭。
Oh, I kind of wish that was still in there. I know. I know. Well, Angela, a few people wrote in about this scene because they noted that when you start dating Andy, you have no problem with everyone in the office knowing it. Oh, well, Angela revenge dates Andy, you guys. Andy is not her true love that she wants to protect
哦，我真希望这一段还留着。我知道。我知道。好吧，安吉拉，有几个人写信谈到这场戏，因为他们注意到，当你开始和安迪约定时，你一点也不介意办公室里的每个人都知道。哦，好吧，安吉拉这是在通过和安迪约会来进行报复，伙计们。安吉拉并不是真爱安迪，她不是想保护他
and keep all to herself because it's so special. She's starting to date Andy because she's mad as hell at Dwight. Right. Very different motivation. Right. In the meantime, Karen and Jim have gone to coffee and Karen is going to ask Jim if he had feelings for Pam. And, lady, I have a clip.
并把他藏起来因为这段感情太特殊。她开始和安迪约会是因为她对德怀特气得要死。没错。动机完全不同。没错。与此同时，凯伦和吉姆去喝咖啡了，凯伦要问吉姆他是否对帕姆有感觉。而且，天哪，我有一个片段。
Sam, play the clip because everything you need to know is right here, Karen. Why couldn't you hear it? Let me ask you a question. Okay. Do you ever have a thing for Pam? Pam? Did I ever have a thing for her?
萨姆，播放那个片段，因为你需要知道的一切都在这里，凯伦。你为什么听不到？我问你一个问题。好吧。你对帕姆有过感觉吗？帕姆？我以前对她有过感觉吗？
No. Why did she do something? It's so clear. That's all you need to know, Karen, he clearly has a thing for her, but poor Karen, she, you know, he convinces her that he doesn't. Maybe he's not ready to admit it, right? And she is not ready to really see truth, but you know down deep, she knows.
没有。怎么了，她做了什么吗？太明显了。这就是你需要知道的全部，凯伦，他对她显然有感觉，但可怜的凯伦，她，你知道的，他连哄带骗让她相信他没有。也许他还没准备好承认，对吧？而她也还没准备好真正面对真相，但你心知肚明，她其实是知道的。
Well, lady, she says, I moved here. Yeah, I moved here. And I think that's the part of Karen that doesn't want to see the truth because it's a little humiliating to deal with the fact that you moved somewhere for the wrong person. Exactly. We all have a friend who has moved somewhere for someone and then it didn't work out.
好吧，女士，她说，我搬到这儿来了。对，我搬到这儿来了。我觉得这就是凯伦不愿面对真相的那部分，因为为了错误的人搬到某个地方这种事实，面对起来多多少少有点羞耻。确实如此。我们都有过这样的朋友，为了某个人搬到一个地方，结果却没有好下场。
It's devastating. But then they hang on to it because they moved. Yeah. And it's like you want, you're willing it to be right, even though you know it's wrong. So this is the moment where I know we've been coming down kind of hard on wishy-washy Jim, but this is the moment where Karen is now not reading the signals.
这太令人崩溃了。但他们还是咬牙坚持，因为他们已经搬了。对。这就好像你希望、你极力促成它是对的，尽管你内心深处知道它是错的。所以这就是那个时刻，我知道我们之前对优柔寡断的吉姆有点严厉，但这就是凯伦现在没有看懂信号的时刻。
No, no. So, and should we go back to Dunder Mifflin to this grand announcement from Dwight? Yes. I mean, he makes this huge like speech and basically he's like, I'm quitting. So I quit. Yeah.
不，不。所以，我们是不是该回到邓德米夫林，听听德怀特的这个重大宣布？没错。我是说，他发表了这么一大通演讲，基本上就是，老子不干了。所以我辞职了。对。
He quits rather than reveal his secret about his relationship with Angela and where he was this morning. He quits. Dwight leaves. He gives Michael his box of things. He does keep his Dwight bobblehead. I'll let you know.
比起暴露他与安吉拉的恋情秘密以及今天早上的行踪，他选择了辞职。他辞职了。德怀特离开了。他把他的杂物盒交给迈克尔。他确实留下了他的德怀特摇头娃娃。我得告诉你们。
Of course. There is a deleted scene where he goes around and gives us all items from the box Jenna. It's very funny. I remember shooting that. Yeah. And then he walks out and he does his salute. It's the same salute from the initiation.
当然。有一个被删的片段，他四处走动，把盒子里的东西分给我们每个人，詹娜。非常搞笑。我记得当时拍了。对。然后他走了出去，行了个军礼。这跟入职仪式上的军礼是同一个。
Nice little call back there. And Dwight is gone. Yeah. And Angela, he has a line that, oh my gosh, he says in a talking head as he's leaving, there's this line where he said, I really believed I was going to die in that chair. That he was so committed to Dunder Mifflin
真是一个不错的首尾呼应。然后德怀特就走了。对。而且安吉拉，他有一句台词，哦天哪，他在离开时对着镜头自白说，有这么一句台词，他说，我真的相信我会死在那张椅子上。他对邓德米夫林是多么忠诚，
he thought he would die in his sales chair. I mean, oh, I have no doubt that's ultimately how it ends for Dwight someday. If the series would have gone. Yeah. In fan fiction, if you write the end, I see Dwight's funeral like, you know, have you ever heard of these funeral homes
以至于他以为自己会死在销售椅上。我是说，哦，我毫不怀疑这最终会是德怀特某天的结局。如果剧集能一直拍下去的话。对。在同人小说里，如果你来写结局，我能想象到德怀特的葬礼就像是，你知道的，你听说过这些殡仪馆吗？
that would stage family members doing their favorite activity? No. I have never heard of a funeral where a person is staged doing their favorite activity. So like, for example, if you love fishing since we've been talking about fishing. Yes.
他们会把家属摆成正在做他们最喜欢的事情的姿势？没有。我从来没听说过有人死后被摆成正在做自己最喜欢的事情的姿势的葬礼。所以比如说，如果你喜欢钓鱼，既然我们一直在聊钓鱼。对。
The person would be staged like in a boat with a fishing rod? Yes. I saw a show. I saw a show all about it. Don't ask me. I think I was like just channel surfing, looking for something. But like, it's like a thing you can get
那个人会被摆成坐在船里拿着鱼竿的姿势？对。我看过一个节目。我看过一个专门讲这个的节目。别问我。我想我当时就像是在随便按遥控器找点东西看。但这就好像是，你可以选择的一种服务，
and they have devices that prop people up and things. But like, let's say you love surfing. You'd be posing on your surfboard. It's a real thing. And then instead of like a wake where they come and view the body and you're in the casket, like, and you say you're goodbye, you're on your surfboard.
他们有装置把人撑起来什么的。但是，比如说你喜欢冲浪。你就会摆出在冲浪板上的姿势。这是真事儿。然后与其举办那种大家来看遗体、你躺在棺材里、大家跟你道别的告别仪式，不如你就待在你的冲浪板上。
Well, if it were me, I guess I would be propped up maybe watching TV, eating a bowl of frozen yogurt or making bread. And you can come say goodbye to me. I'd be, you know, hanging my hummingbird feeder and holding a glass of wine, I guess. Oh, Angela, now I want this for your funeral. If I outlive you, if I outlive you,
好吧，如果是我，我想我大概会被撑起来看着电视，吃一碗冷冻酸奶或者烤面包。然后你可以来跟我道别。我大概会，你知道的，挂着我的蜂鸟喂食器，手里端着一杯葡萄酒。哦，安吉拉，现在我希望你的葬礼也这样。如果我比你活得久，如果我比你活得久，
I am going to pose you with a hummingbird feeder in one hand and a glass of rosé in the other. And I'm going to come say goodbye to you. I will talk to you for hours. Please have it be a real hummingbird feeder with real hummingbird food and maybe they'll come take a drink while I'm standing there. Oh, please.
我要让你一只手拿着蜂鸟喂食器，另一只手端着一杯桃红葡萄酒来摆造型。然后我要去跟你道别。我会跟你聊上好几个小时。拜托一定要是一个真的蜂鸟喂食器，里面有真正的蜂鸟花蜜，也许在我站那儿的时候它们还会来喝一口呢。哦，求你了。
Okay, okay. Done and done. But yes, I guess your point was that perhaps Dwight's funeral, he would have been staged at his Dunder Mifflin desk. Okay. Taking a sales call. At the funeral home, there's even a lookbook that you can flip through.
好吧，好吧。一言为定。不过是的，我想你的意思是，也许德怀特的葬礼上，他会被摆成坐在邓德米夫林办公桌前的姿势。好吧。正在接推销电话。在殡仪馆，甚至还有一本图册供你翻阅。
Oh yeah, I'll take exhibit A at the desk, typing on the keyboard pose. Wow. I feel like you could do some real passive aggressive stuff with this. Like whoever is in charge of your funeral. You could be like, oh, you want to know Larry's favorite activity? I'll tell you what it was. It was Marjorie.
哦对，我要选A号展品，坐在办公桌前打键盘的姿势。哇。我觉得你可以用这个搞出一些非常被动攻击的操作。比如不管谁负责你的葬礼。你可以说，哦，你想知道拉里最喜欢的活动是什么吗？我来告诉你那是什么。是玛乔丽。
I was going to say it was. So I posed him holding his. God, why is that cracking me up so much? People go for the funeral. They're like, what is going on? And we're like, Larry's favorite activity. Being a to Marjorie online. Yeah.
我本想说是。所以我摆出的造型是他拿着他的。天哪，为什么这件事让我笑得停不下来？大家去参加葬礼。他们会想，这到底是怎么回事？而我们会说，拉里最喜欢的活动。在网上当玛乔丽的舔狗。对。
So that's Marjorie. Bye. That's Marjorie's picture on the computer. That's him holding a shmini. I paid $5,000 for this. Thank you, Larry. Oh my God. Okay.
所以那是玛乔丽。再见。那是玛乔丽在电脑上的照片。那是他拿着一个迷你吉祥物。我为此花了5000美元。谢谢你，拉里。哦，天哪。好吧。
Oh my goodness. Okay. Listen. And Marjorie, meanwhile Marjorie's like, I didn't know anyone knew. I, oh my God. My God. Marjorie's husband, Joe is like super shocked. He's like Marge.
哦，天哪。好吧。听着。而玛乔丽，与此同时玛乔丽会说，我不知道有人知道。我，哦，天哪。天哪。玛乔丽的丈夫乔会觉得超级震惊。他会说，玛吉。
What's. Hey, it's all in laundry and betrayal on lifetime. We just wrote our script lady. The big reveal at the funeral. Okay. Okay. So now, now we have this amazing, we have to get it together. Okay.
怎么。嘿，这全在终身频道的《洗涤与背叛》里呢。我们刚刚写好了剧本，女士。葬礼上的惊天大反转。好吧。好吧。所以现在，现在我们有这个精彩绝伦的，我们得稳住。好吧。
Oh my God. Okay. Now we have this amazing Andy talking head. It's a Willy Wonka callback. It's awesome. It goes a little something like Oompa Loompa Dippity Dossum Dwight is now gone, which is totally awesome. Yeah.
哦，天哪。好吧。现在我们有这个精彩的安迪面对镜头独白。这是一个对《查理和巧克力工厂》的致敬。太棒了。它大概是这样的：奥柏马柏矮人豆，德怀特现在已经走，这实在是太棒啦。对。
I was like, who wrote this talking head? Who wrote this? And in the DVD commentary, they said it was Mike. Sure. Oh, there you go. Yeah. Ed said that Mike was in the room with him when he was doing his talking head and they were riffing around and, and they found this one.
我当时就在想，谁写的这段独白？谁写的？然后在DVD花絮评论里，他们说是迈克写的。没错。哦，原来如此。对。埃德说，迈克在他做独白时就在房间里，他们在一边即兴发挥，然后就想出了这个。
And it's so, it's so perfect. And then of course Angela in the background of this talking head, the camera finds you hovering in the background giving a death stare. Oh yeah. Death stare. I remember this so vividly. So Greg was like, Angela, I really want you to glare, like really be angry. Just like Andy is going down.
这实在是，太完美了。然后当然，在这段独白的背景里，镜头捕捉到了安吉拉在背景里徘徊，投来死亡凝视。哦对。死亡凝视。我对此记忆犹新。所以格雷格当时说，安吉拉，我真的需要你怒视，表现得真的很生气。就像安迪要完蛋了那样，
You hate him glare at him. So I did. And he came up to me and he was like, can you give me more? I was like, what? He was like, even harder. I want you to, I just need the death stare of all death stares. I did it again. He's like, Angela, even more.
你恨他，狠狠地瞪他。所以我照做了。他走到我面前说，你能再狠一点吗？我当时想，什么？他说，再凶一点。我需要你，我只需要终极死亡凝视。我又做了一次。他说，安吉拉，再来一点。
I wrote about it in my journal. I said, Greg kept saying one more time, Angela, more mad, more by the end. My eyeballs were shaking in my head. I wrote down, Angela, did you get a headache? Yes. I had the sci-fi bun. I was giving the super death stare and truly by the end, I think you can ever so slightly see me shaking.
我在日记里写过这事儿。我说，格雷格不停地说“再来一次，安吉拉，更生气一点，再生气一点”。到最后，我的眼球在脑子里直打晃。我在日记里写下，安吉拉，你头疼了吗？是的。我顶着那个科幻发髻。我还翻着超级死亡凝视，说实话到最后，我想你甚至能隐隐约约看到我在发抖。
That's how like angry my stare is that I'm like, I was curious if you like popped a blood vessel in your eyeball or something. It is so intense. I was about to. I'm not kidding. It is a great way to end the episode. I do have a fan question, Angela. Okay.
我的眼神就是愤怒到这种程度，以至于我整个人都在抖。我很好奇你当时有没有在眼球里爆血管什么的。实在是太强烈了。我差点就爆了。我没开玩笑。这是结束这一集的好方法。安吉拉，我确实有一个粉丝提问。好的。
And I don't mean to unravel the entire plot of this show. What? But it's a good question. Okay. It comes from Grace D and she says, why couldn't Angela just bring her own tax forms to corporate? She has too many cats, Grace. Well, and also we know from the deleted scenes, some one of her cats just had a litter of kittens that she's dealing with.
我不是故意要推翻整部剧的剧情。什么？但这是一个好问题。好吧。来自格蕾丝·D，她说，为什么安吉拉不自己把纳税申报表带到总公司去？她养了太多猫了，格蕾丝。好吧，而且从删除的片段中我们知道，她的其中一只猫刚刚生了一窝小猫，她正忙着应付呢。
That was my first thought to Angela. I was kind of stumped by that at first. And I was like, yeah, why didn't Angela just go to New York herself? But then I was like, no, she probably has, she probably gets up very early and has like a 90 minute cat routine she has to do every morning. Yes. Putting ointment on eyes and medicines and grooming, right? Yes.
我对安吉拉的第一反应也是这个。我一开始被这个给难住了。然后我想，对啊，为什么安吉拉不自己去一趟纽约呢？但后来我想，不，她可能，她可能起得很早，每天早上都得进行长达90分钟的猫咪日常护理。没错。给眼睛上眼药水、喂药还有梳理毛发，对吧？是的。
And getting the litter boxes ready for the day and setting out food for all of them. I think she has a full morning before she gets to work and especially if she had a litter of kittens and I think she was probably stressing out and going through this whole list with Dwight and he just said, I'll take them. Don't worry. I'll do it. I'll do it. Yes.
还得为新的一天准备好猫砂盆，给它们所有的猫咪准备好食物。我觉得她在去上班前有一整套晨间流程，特别是如果她还照顾一窝小猫的话，我觉得她当时可能压力山大，正和德怀特过着这份长长的清单，而他只是说，我带去。别担心。我去。我去。是的。
That's right. The choices for Dwight were take the forms to New York or do the cat care list. And he was like, I choose forms to New York. Yeah. But good question, Grace. I thought valid question. Valid question. Valid question.
没错。德怀特的选项要么是把表格带到纽约，要么是做猫咪护理清单。于是他选择了：我选把表格带到纽约。对。不过好问题，格蕾丝。我觉得是个言之有理的问题。言之有理的问题。言之有理的问题。
Well, lady, that is traveling salesman. Next week we head into the return. Yes. And the return is the return for several people. And it's such a fun episode. So we will see you next week. All right. Bye, guys.
好吧，女士，这就是《推销员出差》。下周我们将进入《归来》。对，而《归来》就是好几个人回归。这是一个非常有趣的剧集。所以我们下周见。好的。再见，伙计们。
Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwool, Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubacow. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com.
再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwool、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音频工程师是萨姆·基弗。我们的副制作人是艾恩斯莉·巴巴科夫。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。
For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
要免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用优惠码 Office。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。